some crazy woman
rammed the security at mar-a-lago which
is which which is donald trump's winter
white house of course you all know that
and she was just found not guilty and i
was surprised to hear it until i read
further and it said by reason of
insanity and that and then i thought
is trump derangement syndrome becoming
an actual diagnosis because i remember
that big story about trump trump anxiety
disorder and now you have this lady who
actually like attacked the facility
well
the reality is she was literally off her
meds but i think it's interesting
considering just how insane many people
have become
and the crazy thing to me about
everything happening is
particularly with the medical narrative
going on if you understand my my
reference the gas lighting that joe
biden can come out and say we're going
to stop the spread we're going to slow
the spread and now we here we are today
and it's just
the gas lighting is insane as if people
can't remember what was said five
minutes ago or they just keep accepting
what the media tells them when the story
changes every day at a certain point i'm
like yo it's gonna change again tomorrow
but we'll talk about all this we got a
bunch of other stories too we got um
the murder rate skyrocketing across the
u.s we've got the debt it's the democrat
in uh in florida talking about ron
santos or what's up yeah nicki freed
yeah saying that he was what like hitler
or something wow well great okay well
well joining us to talk about all of the
the absurdities of the modern condition
is carrie wedler how's it going great
thank you so much for having me i'm glad
to be here do you want to introduce
yourself sure i'm carrie wedler i got my
start on youtube i was radicalized by
ron paul and have evolved since then i
found my way to a news organization
called the antimedia.org where i was
editor-in-chief for years until we were
banned by big tech in 2018
and i'm still just making my dissident
videos out here advocating peace and
freedom and
challenging the establishment and the
government at large sounds fun kind of
like what luke is doing huh crazy talk
you crazy famously it's really nice to
have my anti-statist friend here kerry
heidler uh that's why i decided to also
wear my anti-status t-shirts today that
says war is murder taxation is theft
police are gangs politicians are
criminals it's one of the the you know
less serious shirts that i have it used
to be my tagline when i used to play
video games every time i used to be in a
room with random people i always said
that it started very interesting
conversations sometimes eight-year-olds
would be like oh yeah definitely
sometimes other police officers that are
playing with me be like okay we're gonna
get angry and it was interesting uh
debates and conversations but if you
like the t-shirt and you want it you can
get it on
thebestpoliticos.com and because you do
i'm here thank you so much for coming
carrie it should be a great conversation
i also have my anti-status t-shirt on
says we are change.org that's a good
website i like that can i can i get this
on the best political t-shirts yes you
can okay
i've been a big fan of we are change for
a long time i'm glad that you were the
one that well i don't know you didn't
invent it but you basically ran it for
the
first 20 years well we all started it
was a youth group in the beginning but
uh it all expanded and through more very
interesting ways yeah hey you guys call
me in crosstalk.net ian crossland here
happy to be here i am also here in the
corner pushing buttons very delighted to
have a lovely lady in the studio with us
and happy to fuel my own personal
anarchist fires that i learned about all
this stuff let's get going before we get
started my friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
biotrusts ageless multi-collagen at 51
off as you know i am an aging
skateboarder and recently started
rollerblading and so my knees are always
banged up my joints are all screwed up
this stuff does wonders i believe ian
actually just put some in his coffee it
dissolves wonderfully it uh there's no
real taste on flavor just melts right in
and it's really good if you want to
maintain your skin health your nails
your joints just you need collagen so
again go to stronger bones and life.com
for 51 off and you will get a 60 day
money back guarantee the aging the
healthy aging support of collagen in its
ideal forms for every order today
biotrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org today biotrust has provided
over 5 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 6
million meals this year their ageless
multi-collagen is non-gmo free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbst nearly no
odor or taste unlike bone broth there's
no clumping unlike other supplements
you'll get free shipping you will get
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order shout out to biotrust for
sponsoring the show go to
strongerbonesandlife.com but don't
forget you can also go to timcast.com
support us directly as a member and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments the tim cast irl podcast
as well as the knowledge that your
membership is supporting all of our
journalists we're hiring some more
people
we're going to be expanding our security
we do have some people are like why
don't you we do have security but we're
going to hire more and so with your
support as a member we will reinforce
the compound i'm somewhat kidding but we
will add on security we'll be hiring
more journalists we're gonna be working
on new shows and it's all thanks to you
so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends now let's get
into that first story from the daily
mail
connecticut opera singer who rammed
through mar-a-lago security blockade and
narrowly escaped secret service bullets
in january 2020 is found not guilty by
reason of insanity hannah romhild 32 was
found not guilty by reason of insanity
on tuesday her attorney said she had a
history of mental illness and had
stopped taking her medication before she
drove through the
mar-a-lago security blockade she must
undergo psychiatric treatment and
counseling and take medications with
monthly blood tests to confirm
compliance
she pulled her rented jeep into the
parking lot of the breakers a luxury
hotel and began dancing on her car and
making obscene gestures she led police
in a dangerous chase where police and
secret service fired at her vehicle as
she swerved checkpoints she then drove
to the airport to pick up her mother
okay before being arrested at a nearby
motel
so i don't know if this lady was
actually motivated by anything political
but seeing stories like this i have to
wonder
i was i was on twitter and i saw some
people making posts about how their
therapist had said this that or
otherwise and i thought to myself it's
kind of weird that all of these like
democrat personalities have therapists
right
is there something to this that people
with trump derangement syndrome
they don't
they need someone to help them think
properly be it or maybe a medication on
them think properly or
i think when you live in the
military-industrial complex in the
empire the heart of the empire it's hard
not to go crazy i particularly when i
lived in la for like eight nine years i
thought i needed a therapist it wasn't
until i started speaking my mind on the
internet fluidly daily monday through
friday that i stopped feeling the need
to look outside for help because i'm
finding it here within myself or at
least in this table conversation yeah if
you live in major uh city areas the
likelihood of you having mental health
issues actually goes up dramatically
compared to the suburbs but uh with this
particular story who said it doesn't pay
to be crazy right i mean she got off had
all of her charges dropped but on a
serious note there is a mental health
crisis that this country is dealing with
that is getting worse by the day and
there has been a lot of circumstantial
evidence suggesting that it's because of
social media use again circumstantial
evidence correlation does not prove
causation but i think it's fair to say a
lot of people are losing their marbles
losing their minds there's a lot of
doctors easily prescribing ssris easily
prescribing uh addictive painkillers to
individuals that have an effect on their
life you want early treatment for for
covet no no no no pain kills ssris poop
you're gonna get it right away which is
absolutely uh crazy with how our medical
institution is run today dana white
brought that up you know he's at a press
conference and he's like i bet i can get
these pain pills before i get monoclonal
antibodies but uh the other thing too is
we were talking about with cnn when when
i think it was like brian stelter he was
like the trauma of january 6th the
journalists trauma
like they're sitting in an
air-conditioned
building in new york city they're
nowhere near the capital and they're
experiencing trauma
well look at this story from vox back in
2021 people are not okay the mental
health impact of the trump era yo i got
a solution it's not therapy it's not
medication it's turning off the computer
it's turning off the monitor screen and
going and like i don't know smelling
flowers or something turn it off the
boob tube yeah like turn off the tv turn
off the fear-mongering when you look at
what the the corporate media feeds into
people's minds it is absolute trash and
garbage it is some of the most
destructive negative low vibrational
thinking that you could have in your
existence jammed down your throat by dr
fauci by anderson cooper by all these
smear merchants saying breaking news
fear-mongering you're supposed to be
afraid because of this today you're
supposed to give up your rights because
of this today you're supposed to live in
your pod eat the bugs be in the
metaverse because it is good for you and
then people are following those orders
doing what they're told and they're
learning that they're they're miserable
gee i wonder why well i don't think
there's anything wrong with therapy
whatsoever i think and this might be a
controversial opinion but i don't think
there's anything even wrong with being
emotional i know there's a big backlash
against the left because they're so
emotional i would argue they are
emotional but it's unmitigated reactive
emotion being human you're gonna have
emotions so i think the issue here is
really that people don't have a
container to hold their emotions and
therefore they act out in ways like this
and you end up with chaos all over the
place in fact i think the solution of
that is to be more comfortable with
emotion to be able to able to better
feel it and hold space for yourself and
of course others but i think it's
people's inability to do that that leads
to this
chaos over emotional reaction like um
pharmaceutical drugs like what do you
pinpoint is the the reason why people
are having a difficult time with their
emotions right now i mean i think people
have always struggled with emotions like
to be human is to suffer and this is
sort of a buddhist belief but i mean who
hasn't suffered who hasn't felt
difficult emotions i think it's people's
tendency to want to avoid the discomfort
by say taking pills and i'm not saying
it's never appropriate to take pills if
you have a mental health condition i
don't know your experience i don't know
why you would be on them but i think
obviously they're over prescribed and i
think that's ultimately an attempt by
people and their providers to just numb
it out instead of just building the
inner resources to be able to sit with
it and there's a ton of stuff in our
society that incentivizes avoiding
feelings avoiding expressing your
emotions avoiding dealing with any kind
of hardship or any kind of hard truth
realities as they're giving everyone
medals as they're congratulating
everyone and and denying them the basic
truth of this world that it is difficult
it is hard it's not fair life will never
be fair but these people are told it's
always going to be fair everything's
going to be fine you're going to get a
trophy just by participating and they're
realizing holy crap the real world
doesn't work that way they're having a
big reality check they don't know how to
deal with those emotions they go online
and they they're consumed by the
algorithms that control them or by other
adult content especially young children
are doing this that they shouldn't be
watching that rewires their brain to be
working in such negative horrible ways
that creates destructive relationships
and disharmony in people's personal
lives i think
a lot of people over the past seven
years you know since the start of the
media's obsession with trump have been
dealing with an ever-shifting news
landscape that keeps changing its
opinions and mocking people when they
don't know exactly what the new
narrative is so if you take a look at
like i don't know joe biden comes out
and he says
if you get the vaccine this is joe biden
saying this it's going to stop the
spread of covet paraphrasing now that's
not true today they say it will reduce
the severity of symptoms but there's a
major shift so if you're somebody who's
like i don't know you're uh
you're an accountant you know you don't
watch the news all day every day you see
this story and you're like okay i see
the president speaking
the news changes
and then you see the news again a week
later and it's a 180 from where they
were and now you're sitting there saying
like has anyone noticed this you're
thinking to yourself something doesn't
make sense and then you go to someone or
you go online and you post like this
seems strange to me and what happens
they attack you for it you get attacked
you get insulted you get smeared i think
this is driving people insane it's
making people insane you look at the
news about trump and the media lies
every single day and it's escalating and
getting worse and worse and all the lies
and and they've still been lying about
the guy even though it's been you know a
year or a long a little bit longer than
a year since he was in the office or
just about a year since he was in office
they keep lying
but you can't have these these different
things be true at the same time
but if you try and speak out you'll be
attacked for it seems like there's three
types of insanity there's the people
that believe that the narrative shift
and without questioning it that's a type
of insanity just going with the flow
then there's the people that question
the change in the narrative and call it
out and get
called insane and then they start to go
insane because they're like why am i
being attacked for questioning this then
there's the people that see it all and
think it's all crazy those people are
just considered insane
that's kind of where i'm at anyway i
mean i i tweet about this stuff and i
actually have like prominent politically
homeless journalists
uh responding to me saying like well the
new narrative is is is this
you know particularly talking about
vaccines here's the new narrative and
i'm like how did how did we shift in
three months
dramatically on whatever the narrative
is currently i will not be gaslit sorry
i don't care and so i think what happens
when you have people like this woman she
goes insane i mean granted she was on
meds got off her meds that i get but
there are a lot of people like this that
are angry and insane and it's because
how do you vent your frustrations with
an ever-changing
world
you you have a world view but it's not
solidified because people keep changing
and lying i think yuri besmanov talks
about this demoralization about
eventually people are just like i can't
tell what's real anymore because the
news is changing what they said a month
ago and then they
and then they drive a car through a
checkpoint screaming and dancing and
making obscene gestures because they're
just their brains
erupt yep in a sick society mental
illness is a byproduct of it and someone
said today and i tweeted this officially
saying that the bankers will ensure that
we stay in debt the pharmaceutical
companies will ensure that we stay sick
the weapons manufacturers will ensure
that we keep going to war the media will
ensure we are prevented from knowing the
truth the government will ensure all of
this is done legally and i think we're
living in this kind of society that has
almost every step that people take in it
uh set for them as a trap that benefits
only the ruling elites and creates mass
human suffering for everyone else sorry
i cut you off karen that's okay now just
to speak to the gaslighting especially
when it comes to the media let's just
say let's just say that everything they
report now is completely accurate and
true and vetted and they're being
completely honest even then
given their decades if not longer track
record of blatantly lying of blatantly
peddling government narratives you still
like how are you going to be angry at
someone for not trusting them even if
they were telling the truth right now
because of the history how could you
possibly shame someone for having
hesitations i think it's because
you're showing that you're free you've
you've exited the cave where the
silhouettes are dancing and some of
these people are aware they're being
lied to and they don't have the courage
to do what you've done so they would
rather stand with the mob and say no
right crabs in a bucket they're going to
pull you back in attack you but i'll
tell you this man i don't i don't
remember the exact quote from breitbart
that i've that has been brought up
several times something about like you
know go towards the fire on the other
side is freedom it was something like
that yeah i remember exactly but that
what i was told it was explained to me
is that everybody is standing around and
there's this wall of fire they're
terrified and they're told by one around
you don't go near it it's bad and some
people say i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna run and jump through
it and on the other side it's a party
it's a beach there's the ocean there's
food and they're like you made it out
congratulations and on the other side is
freedom and there are people trapped
inside scared to come out and find that
yo man
it's freeing right the funny thing about
this there was this post that went viral
during the during trump's first campaign
and it was someone took
a coming out story about a guy who was
gay
and they changed gay to trump supporter
and it was funny because it went viral
all the trump supporters were like wow
this resonates with me because the
person was saying things like i wasn't
being true to myself i was hiding who i
was i was scared that if i told people
the truth about what i thought and what
i felt they would attack me and they
would smear me and then it ended up
getting picked up because trump
supporters resonated with it when it was
applied to their views i think that was
a a big thing that the internet helped
to make it's one of the reasons why
censorship is so big it's one of the
reasons why they're trying to ban
everybody because community is important
to tell you
when you hear that voice on the other
side of the wall of flame telling you
hey man we're all chilling it's fine
just just jump through and like we're
partying and then people go for it and
they're like this is so much better i
don't have to freak out
it's not confusing anymore i don't have
to worry about those people being
attacked there's a community they'll
support we will support each other but
for the people who are trapped inside
the matrix it's terrifying interesting
this your metaphor goes right up along
mine whereas if the government was like
an abusive father in a relationship and
like beating up the kids you and your
siblings and then one night there's a
fire in the house and the dad's like
come on we gotta get out we gotta get
out and you're like no i don't trust you
you've been abusive and your siblings
like dude
it's an emergency covet in this in this
metaphor it's an emergency we have to
listen to the abusive guy even though we
don't want to because he's the authority
but then you realize the flames aren't
hot i mean that's it along with your
metaphor it's an elusive emer
well this needs to be an elusive
emergency and this
it's a difficult analogy i mean i think
covet is is nasty right i know it is
nasty but the reaction of it is insane
really exactly
nasty man yeah ian and i had had kovid
uh uh like comparably bad yeah he almost
died both of you well
you know we were both it was too early
to tell yeah four days in of no
treatment and i was like i'm ready to
try something how to do something i was
i i called the hospital yeah that's how
bad i had and i'm like it's it's
seriously bad but you're right the
response has been insane but more
importantly
i'm i'm reading the media narratives on
social media and it's just i'm sorry man
people are
insane
they're insane i'm sorry
if you know that the narrative is bunk
on a lot of this stuff
on policy especially on mandates but you
keep just agreeing with whatever it is
fauci says next even though if we were
to play every sound bite from every
interview it would be the most
nonsensical garbage you've ever heard if
you're gonna go along with that you are
willfully lying you are nuts yeah so i
was talking about this on the way home
last night and we came up with the
conclusion that it's probably that they
have too much sunk into this this is
very much a sunk cost fallacy
application because they've wrapped
their whole identity into following the
leader and to i guess for lack of a
better expression following this mass
formation psychosis thing where they
have one leader it's very scary it's
very much crisis in leviathan where they
have this big terrifying emergency and
this lovely government leadership is
going to come and show them exactly what
to do they don't really have because
they lack community they lack their
families they lack their churches
whatever it used to be they're like i
have to follow someone i don't really
even have any friends which i think is
part of the reason that they need some
form of
therapy even when they may not
necessarily just because they lack
friends in any kind of social life
um and they end up being like okay i
can't change my views i have too much
invested in this i can't change my mind
it has to be true or else what am i
standing for
well if you've if you've invested years
into this right and now
you know you're starting to recognize
that fauci has flip-flopped every day
non-stop
i feel like people's brains are just
like at this point just a mishmash of
broken
broken reality i get like war weariness
um from the insanity of 25 21 years of
conquest of war and pharmaceuticals
making people psychotic i'm interested
in to know your perspective perception
on this over the last i don't know how
long you were with ana media like a
decade ago right um
i started 2014 and we were abandoned
in journalism before that no
what was your observation of people
going if you i don't even know if you
think people have gone crazy but
people's mental state over the last
decade yeah you know i think there's
always been issues i don't i think the
people really losing it now it didn't
just come out of nowhere they probably
already had
struggles and things they were dealing
with and then it became much more
exacerbated like i think if you're a
generally well-grounded person which i
don't know i don't know how common that
is but i think in general if you have
inner resources
you might be frustrated you might be
scared but i don't think you can go to
the
to the spirals some people have fallen
into because i really see it gets to the
point where people are i mean
you can cite cdc data and people will
still tell you you're crazy and you're
selfish and you're propagandized and
you're literally citing their authority
and they'll still they can't even
register for that stephen crowder got a
strike on youtube for citing the cdc
right and so we we've talked about that
when it comes to uh the modern vaccine
narrative i'm just like i don't even
know what youtube's rules are at this
point because i listen to dr fauci and
i'm like well if i say that youtube bans
us because youtube says you can't say
that but fauci's saying it so i'm like i
don't even know at this point the
pressure is reaching that point where
you know we're saying like listen
we want to be reasonable people we want
to talk about what's going on but when
youtube outright says you can't discuss
things that they themselves discuss or
cnn discusses they give crowder a strike
over it i'm like yo you're asking for
people for their brains to just explode
because you're backing people into a
corner and sooner or later they're going
to say i'm mad as hell and i'm not going
to take it anymore yep
it's true it's like uh giving a if if
youtube where i don't like the metaphor
sword fight but if youtube and then they
give you like a plastic sword because
you're not allowed to say the stuff they
say
so like how fun is that i mean it's
life-threatening so i'm not gonna play
sorry michael knowles made the
observation the other day that it
doesn't matter what you say it matters
who says it right right stephen crowder
says it he's gone fauci says it he's
fine doesn't matter anyway bill gates
yeah not a doctor yeah no rogan also not
exactly i don't like the way it doesn't
matter like i saw somebody get banned i
think carl benjamin off of somebody
else's so like what will happen is that
rather than target the channel that
makes the banneable offense they target
the individual that started the channel
so then if they start a new channel with
a completely different theme
they'll whack a mole it doesn't make any
sense the channel hasn't banned any
terms and conditions
so we we saw recently ethan klein of the
h3 podcast and he announced he was
deleting several episodes two episodes
he had with jordan peterson yeah i i
feel bad for the guy a lot of people are
mad they're like oh that's a stupid
thing to do and cancel culture and all
that and i'm like dude did you guys do
you follow him and do you know why this
is happening to him by all means
criticize ethan h3 for their politics
that's totally fine and that's that's
the political landscape but what's
happening is someone went on his youtube
channel from a really old video and they
mass reported it and he got a strike
which took his channel offline for a
week he has employees he he needs to
make sure people are paying the bills
now i think his reaction to this was
really really bad what he ends up doing
is saying
i'm going to go back and delete past
episodes which can probably get me
another strike what people need to
understand about youtube and censorship
and all that is that
i've got
we've got tim cast irl where it is a
variety of people but includes me
talking about news and politics i have
youtube.comcastnews
which is me monologuing right and then
youtube.comcast which is me talking
about big stories of the day but they're
so similar i was told by youtube that if
i get one strike on any of these
channels even though they're different
shows i can't do any of the shows that
doesn't make sense because if someone on
one of your shows like a guest does
something that can happen that doesn't
make sense for you to have any kind of
issues i i think you guys should revisit
that no that youtube has outright said
we don't care yeah so if the show is is
in any way related when you get a strike
you're done so you can't work for a week
and that means the the this is kind of i
mean today we would just go on rumble we
would say okay so this is what i was
saying in a video i talked about this
with ethan klein i said he should have
went on rumble and set up his podcast
there and just said here's why we're
taking these episodes down we'll upload
them to rumble so people can watch them
instead he went the political route and
i disagree with this even klein has long
been a comedic edge lord where he said
offensive things and that's why they're
going after him but the reason he's
taking down these podcasts in my opinion
with jordan peterson is because
they can go to a three or four year old
video
get it flagged because youtube changed
the rules later on
and then his whole company gets shut
down so his response to all this was
i'm taking it all down he has he's been
losing subscribers for whatever reason i
don't know i think this may be related
to it because he did this thing with
hassan [ __ ] the left-wing streamer they
did his collaboration and then he lost a
ton of he gained a bunch of subscribers
and lost a ton of subscribers i wonder
if in his mind he's thinking yo i don't
care about politics i'm just a comedian
guy but they're gonna destroy my
business
unless i bend the knee his choice was to
fall in line and bend the knee i think
it's a mistake but i certainly
understand his fear of censorship not
this is my speculation i could be wrong
but why would someone go in and delete
old shows there's no reason to do that
he nuked eight million views off his
channel and in my opinion it's because
the culture war is escalating the left
and probably the right will go after his
old videos i'd be willing to bet there
are people who are going to start
flagging his content because
he's announced he's doing left-wing
content with his son
and you could never appease the mob so
no matter how many times he apologizes
there's still clips of him saying some
absolutely absurd stuff in the name of
free speech that people are going to
bring up and use against them the
strategic move that should have been
done here is build your own platform
build up your own website build up uh
your own subscription model have an
alternative to youtube because all the
writings were on the wall even in 2008 i
remember making videos in 2008 being
like hey youtube it's not going to be a
space that is going to be respecting
free speech and we're going to be seeing
this platform restrict speech more as we
go on and of course this is why i built
my website my email list and if even if
they do take me down fine i have
alternatives i have other ways of even
getting payments there's there's ways
that we have moved away from this big
system and i think youtube recognizes
that that that they're not the the all
and be all right now that there's
alternatives and a lot of people are
exploring those i know you did and it's
been extremely strategic it's been
extremely smart and i wish other people
would just implement those same measures
and not be into this control grid that
we're all in you can't stop the internet
that's what it is
they're trying to the establishment
desperate and the elites the
billionaires many of these ultra-wealthy
individuals they desperately want to be
back in that world where there were five
channels
they all marched in lockstep on all the
news stories they all backed up the the
government and the major corporations
they were they could easily snap their
fingers and get us involved in a war and
say iraq like the new york times did and
now it's difficult now some random dude
nabini screams at a camera for a few
years and people watch the show and how
do they get rid of it well they could
outright ban it they go after stephen
crowder they give him a strike even
though he's just citing the cdc that's a
really good example of how they'll lie
cheat and steal but there are limits if
they go too hard then people revolt and
they'll just make new platforms then the
establishment is playing whack-a-mole
game of cat and mouse they'll go after
you know gab and accuse them of all this
other you know nonsense try and get them
banned and then gab builds their own
infrastructure rumble emerges gets
massive institutional investment these
establishment political powers are
losing in my opinion free speech is
winning gun rights are winning and in
that regard i will say i'm fairly
optimistic that authoritarianism will
not be able to prevail because there's
nothing they can do to silence us they
can shut down our twitters but then
getter pops up getter might get crushed
but then people will go to gap it's
never going to stop the internet exists
and they need to learn a deal with it i
think that they're trying to instill a
civil war though in the united states
now they've gone they've given up on
trying to censor people into submission
now they want to see the us fight itself
so that corporate governance can can
take hold i kind of disagree i mean we
look at the latest statements made by
the president of the united states he
was begging social media companies and
the corporate media to start censoring
quote misinformation all in name of
keeping everyone safe dr fauci on the
world economic forum also on his zoom
call was saying we need to fight
disinformation for everyone's health
people are understanding what's going on
here the german government is even
proposing on banning telegram i love
telegram i have a lot of fun on telegram
it's one of the platforms that has truly
risen and has allowed people to talk to
each other without any algorithms
without any central controllers without
anyone dictating what you can and cannot
see people are having real honest civil
discussions for the german government
that's a big no no no no we gotta ban
that we can't allow the plebs to talk to
each other how dare they share ideas and
have informed consent about the
decisions that the plutocrats and
billionaires make for them obviously
it's it's ridiculous to portray this
concept that they're caring for us by
limiting our speech that's a ridiculous
concept and a concept that has been used
historically to oppress people enslave
them and to murder them that's the true
lesson of history that we're learned
here so this is why they're still trying
to censor speech in my opinion yes
less that it's i used to think that the
goal was to censor the speech and be
done with it now i'm starting to think
the goal is to take control of the
world's governance with a corporation
and then the censoring the speech is a
byproduct of that or is establishing the
way towards it i would argue that they
already did it in some ways did work
took over the corporate uh overlords
have taken over government and are using
them as a tool as a vehicle for their
own hands down yeah mark zuckerberg
knows when you poop and it's a funny
it's a funny way to explain the concept
but the algorithms the ai of facebook
knows when you will have a bowel
movement they know who you will vote for
they can then influence you facebook ran
experiments on people without their
knowledge to see if they could make them
depressed
fact check me on that one yeah i could
be wrong but my understanding was they
flooded people's feeds with negative
information to see if they would get sad
and it worked
yeah it was psychological experiments on
unsuspecting facebook users i've been
talking about this for a number of years
now and this is what they were doing
openly admittedly testing and
manipulating people's emotions with the
algorithm seeing how they could change
their emotional state and if they're
doing that with emotions a couple years
ago i think this was over 10 years ago
what do you think they're doing now on
such a complex level with the algorithm
only gaining and becoming more stronger
so if they can make you sad with the
algorithm imagine what else they could
make you do if they tweak the algorithm
in different ways
you find a wife they can make you find
your significant other and it's the one
that they want you to find that's called
eugenics wow dude that's creepy but it's
true yeah if you look at everything the
establishment pushes it's pushing a
system that de-incentivizes the family
unit that perverses people's own
sexuality that bastardizes any kind of
semblance of of love and respect and
harmony for the fellow human being if
you look at every aspect of it it's to
destroy families in the future of this
country so going back to the to the
ethan klein thing with jordan peterson a
lot of people on the left and the right
made this about tribal politics and so i
decided to take a look i was like why
would you delete 8 million views off
your youtube channel i was like even if
even if he he doesn't like jordan
peterson there's a lot of videos he
should be deleting because the things he
cited he's got other videos of that
stuff so why is jordan peterson so i
went and looked at his youtube stats and
i looked at his charitable stats for his
podcast and then i saw that there was a
period where he was you know he was
getting hit he was losing subs then i
saw he posted on instagram that people
flagged his old videos and got his
company shut down and he said i've got
10 employees i've got to pay them i owe
rent they shut my company down and i'm
like there it is
they have successfully coerced him into
playing ball with tribal politics
i think it's a mistake i think he should
have stayed true to himself and he would
have been he would have been a hero of
those he he long stood for but i want to
i want to throw it to you carrie because
you worked for anti-media and there was
something that uh i think was missed by
project veritas and i i could be getting
the story wrong so again you should
faction man this one's been it's been
several years but i remember veritas did
this expose on i think it was pinterest
and there was this blacklist
uh live action was blacklisted it's a
it's a pro-life organization and project
veritas pointed that out when i was
looking at their video when i saw this
report
it lists anti-media and i saw that and i
was like whoa whoa whoa whoa i was like
james and veritas i think they missed it
because they didn't know what it was
they all have everyone has their biases
whether well-intentioned or not and i
think veritas missed that an anti-war
anti-establishment website was also
being censored so so what happened with
all that i actually didn't even know
that pinterest had censored us
i just i think it was pinterest okay
yeah well i remember and i could be
wrong but i think i remember seeing that
google had blacklisted us which makes
sense because we could never get
accepted into google news we'd apply and
apply and we couldn't get in even though
other independent media outlets could
um and this actually reminds me because
we were talking about gaslighting and
the the way the media operates and it's
so after the 2016 election the
washington post came out with an article
about all the misinformation and it was
all spread by you know russia russia was
behind it and all these new news outlets
had were spreading misinformation to
benefit russia and we were put on a list
made by an anonymous group they were
called proper not you can look up this
article search washington post i was on
there too yeah we are on that list as
well and i was like what i'm a russian
asset right
i'm polish like how dare you sorry go
ahead but it's crazy though because i i
was i worked for an organization called
the anti-media like i was clearly i had
already made i had already broken ties
with the mainstream media and i came
from the left i was a you know pretty
mainstream democrat voted for obama and
so i went through quite an evolution
away from that but even then seeing my
name on that list from an authority
figure the washington post i was like
wait am i in some way supporting russia
what have i done and i'm like this is
driving me insane because i'm so
actively i mean we wouldn't even quote
rt unless it was like a russian general
you know we were so careful about not
being aligned with state or with
governments with state-sponsored media
with really being accurate and it got in
my head so much and then of course i was
angry because i was like how are you
gaslighting me this hard that i'm
questioning my own integrity and my own
practices when i know them better than
any person at proper not any anonymous
person
um but it definitely
when the bands happened it was it
happened right after alex jones so i
don't know if you had a specific
question but it was no just just what
happened well i think it's important to
also understand you were de-platformed
in on many different social media
organizations can you tell us how you
were de-platformed how you dealt with it
where you are now yeah so it's
interesting because we actually had a
facebook representative working with our
page and that this is back when facebook
was really big it was still one of the
major platforms nobody uses it anymore i
mean nobody i know but i don't use it um
but we had lost a lot of reach following
the 2016 election we used to have at one
point i had the most viral article in
the world like based on metrics so we
were we were really getting reach and it
wasn't just us it was our partner
partner organizations the free thought
project it was the mind unleashed and it
was always anti-war police
accountability anti-establishment
anti-cronyism you know we talked about
solutions we talked about you know any
i'm sure things that people care about
and uh then out of nowhere let's see
alex jones was banned august 2018 and we
were banned october 2018 right before
the midterms and we'll never be able to
prove exactly why we got a very generic
notice of like inauthentic no that was
twitter that was wait i can't keep track
of all the places we were banned
anti-media was banned on facebook i
believe they said um
it was something about manipulative
behavior we didn't do any of that we
just posted our articles we had partner
pages but regardless
that was in the morning i think it was a
tuesday a tuesday morning we got that
notice and by the afternoon twitter had
banned us as well and my personal
account was banned i think they're
trying to homogenize the media narrative
yeah and so there were too many voices
the ecosystem was expanding it's
expanding
it was expanding rapidly and even right
now it's really difficult for people to
get started on youtube because they want
to make sure there's a very narrow path
you can walk right only if you have an
acceptable voice
and the corporate ties so if you're tied
into major major special interests in
corporations you're going to get pushed
in the algorithm you're a joe schmoe you
have absolutely no chances of making it
what they're doing right now
is they've isolated they've they've
secretly in my opinion based on the data
quarantined channels like this one and
many others now i i think we were
quarantined for some time but we were we
had that lifted for some reason i think
you know we we are on the edge of what
they like they find tolerable and i've
often explained it as a pressure release
valve if they ban too many people at
once everyone just jumps ship and go
somewhere else but if they want to
control people's thoughts what they'll
do is they'll ban some and then make
sure channels like this one remain so
that people won't leave the platform and
they can keep feeding them a narrative
so i i've talked about this in terms of
effective censorship versus what a lot
of these companies had been doing saying
that if you if you give people clear
rules and understanding they'll follow
it but if you ban them out right
you make them jump ship to other
platforms where they maintain and push
and double down
i think that's what they're doing i
think the reason so we were blacklisted
for a while this channel you couldn't
google search it you type in the name
and you get facebook instead of youtube
you type in youtube and try and nothing
none of it would come up
some that changed i think at some point
last year and it was funny we mentioned
on the show then the next day everyone's
like hey you're not blacklisted anymore
and i'm like interesting the first night
i mentioned dmt
all of a sudden they were like not true
by the way
that's what i like to think the machine
l set us free i talked about
psychedelics they're like legit to put
it to put it to put it simply i think
the reason anti-media gets banned the
reason why alex jones gets banned the
reason why they're going after crowder
is because they have the the the the
road they've paved and if you walk off
of it you're out what gets me is that
you got banned on facebook and then
later in that same day on twitter that
makes me think that it wasn't someone at
facebook called someone on twitter and
was like hey that it was somebody above
both organizations was like it's time
that's what it makes it seem like but
that's and that's the thing is
conspiracy i can't claim anything with
certainty and i'm not going to because i
don't know but they had started working
with the atlantic council there i think
it's called the digital forensics
research lab and they were supposed to
be analyzing social media and helping
platforms like facebook and twitter weed
out anything that could threaten
democracy and hurt the integrity of
elections and that council was connected
with henry kissinger who of course is
also a very big fan favorite of we are
change when we were conducting
interviews of him and obviously that
didn't play a role in us getting hit on
the facebook and youtube and twitter and
all that other stuff last year by the
way uh the facebook page that i run on
on we are change got a strike because we
posted a screenshot of the cdc website
talking about breakthrough cases louder
crowder got hit for mentioning cdc
statistics so
it's not even just walking the tight
rope even if you regurgitate the
narrative back at them they still have
the indecency to try to destroy your
livelihood take away everything you
worked so hard for all in a moment's
notice because you're not helping the
multinational corporations you're not
helping the special interest you're not
helping the billionaire's class you're
not helping henry kissinger bill gates
and all these other people push their
agenda onto everyone else so it's
becoming sick and twisted to such a
degree that you can't even talk about
the official story anymore well and it's
it's it's so telling too because the
things we care about the things that we
covered war empire police brutality mass
surveillance these are things that to
many people on the left who are
principled it's this is not taboo to
discuss we're not talking about things
that are out we weren't you know we
weren't
we weren't noticeably right-wing in any
way so all i'm left to believe is that
whoever made these decisions didn't like
the lens we were framing it in it wasn't
that we were anti-war it wasn't that we
were against the empire it was that we
were framing it through an anarchist
lens that was completely outside the
realm of political solutions like voting
or something that people would consider
acceptable we were advocating an
overhaul of the entire thing and i'm
left i mean again i can't say with any
kind of certainty but it seems like that
was the issue i want to i want to
address uh
one of the super chats
before we move on to the next segment
normally we just save it to the end but
people have pointed out that ethan klein
has very very offensive shows where he
makes you know racial slurs and he says
things like that and homophobic slurs oh
yeah yes yes yes i i know and i don't
think that changes my point i think my
point is him getting rid of the jordan
peterson episode is because he's scared
of the left going after him and getting
him banned so he's siding with them in
hopes that it protects him and they
won't go after him it's the metaphor
again is like if a doctor is like hey
that you have an infection we're cutting
it off and you're like ah and then you
start looking around at your body you're
like that might be an infection that
looks like an infection i'm cutting it
off he cuts that off that might be an
infection then everywhere he looks he
starts to see potential infection so
he's cutting his own
your videos off you're missing what i
just said
he has a video on his channel someone
mentioned where he says racial slurs
over and over and over again he hasn't
deleted it it's not an issue of him
saying i've done something wrong it's an
issue of him saying and this proves my
point it's not about him agreeing with
the left it's not about him actually
disagreeing with jordan peterson it's
about him saying this is what will get
me banned if leftists flag my videos
they're not going to go after his
idubbbz thing
they don't care about idubbbz that's
that's what they're mentioning idubbbz
the interview they're going to go after
jordan peterson which will get him in
trouble so i i think he's he's whether
whether he wants to acknowledge it or
not i think this plays a big role in his
political shift he's scared of getting
canceled he's siding with them in hopes
they don't flag his content but you're
saying he has homophobic content he's
not deleting so i i i wouldn't call it
homophobic i would say that he's
intentionally being offensive as
possible by saying a racial and
homophobic slur together over and over
again and he hasn't
i think that would be the first thing he
would want to delete if he's concerned
about people on the left coming after
him not on not if he sides with them you
see oh are they going to go after a
youtube a youtuber
no are they going to go after jordan
peterson yes
so he starts agreeing with them he
starts defending them he starts saying
this seems safe and acceptable they're
not going to flag my content but they
would flag jordan peterson i'm not
saying he's the smartest guy in the
world i'm not saying he's perfect and
there's another comment where they're
saying i'm just defending him i'm like
dude first first and foremost i don't
agree with his politics that's fine
criticize the guy all day and night i'm
pointing out there are people like this
is a guy who was just an edgy comedian
what does he know about politics he's
even said he doesn't know and now he's
getting inundated with attacks so he
decides to stay safe to survive at all
costs like um
who mentioned this uh the other was the
other day they mentioned the gulag
archipelago yeah james james yeah james
right right he was mentioning survival
at all costs that's what this is and
it's strategic
if he really cared about what the left
was saying if he really believed it he
would have deleted that episode he
didn't which says to me it is his fear
of the culture war i got more that he
wanted to do a high profile takedown of
jordan peterson for views that was my
buddy to make a video about it he just
tweeted i mean i'm sure he talked about
it on his new channel but i don't think
he's even done a full-blown you're right
there's more to it yeah but also
everyone everyone's talking about him
now which also achieved the goal of
getting attention for this which could
have been something that he was seeking
potentially and if you removed a bunch
of once
it wouldn't be now he gets to do he can
remove a video every two weeks and stay
in the limelight nice job ethan come on
dude
let's let's let's talk about this story
we got right here from from the
post-millennial
cnn plans to create team dedicated to
covering misinformation oh good do you
feel like you have to jump down every
rabbit hole you see do you get mad when
you see liars taking advantage of people
i do like jake tapper and brian stelter
and um i don't even i don't even what
does
this
he's so irrelevant i forgot the guy's
name
but these people
lie
nonstop
then they go on their tv channel that's
that's dropped in ratings by 90 percent
and they're they're yeah reliable
sources i think i love the irony of the
name right imagine imagine a fire
department called like flaming fire
truck you'd be like
that i don't know if i'd want them to
come like the fire the fire is free tim
a fire truck on fire
is the best way to explain what reliable
sources on cnn means it is one of the
least reliable sources and now they're
going to be telling us that they're
making this you know anti-disinformation
show alex koppelman says some very
exciting media jobs tell you i'm hiring
three people for a new cnn team
dedicated to covering misinformation
throughout the team and job starts here
please feel free to share far and wide
and if you're interested reach out or
apply at the links you know
part of me is frustrated that we talk
about cnn because when i learned that
their ratings were down by over 90 and
they were getting between like 70 and
100 000 in the key demo i was like wow
we should just not talk about them
anymore because they're irrelevant
but they still do have institutional
authority youtube props them up put them
on the front page and then you get 100
million plus youtube views so we need to
make sure we're calling out all of the
lies and manipulations from cnn
this is like ian doing anti-drug
commercials
this makes no sense at all this is like
the ultimate epitome of hypocrisy that
we have to deal with cnn being fact
checkers are you kidding me like i mean
what kind of parallel universe are we
living in where they think they could
pull this off i mean they have no
credibility they have been lying to the
american people non-stop 24 7
fear-mongering and and they're losing
the audience because the audience
understands like hey i don't want to be
spoken down to i don't want to have my
thoughts controlled i don't want to have
my perspectives limited to what you want
me to think they're the perfect
representatives they're pr for the
special ruling elite and they're nothing
else but that i'm i get uh
angrier and angrier you know seeing what
these people do and maybe there's a lot
of people who who watch them don't
understand why i would be so like you
know so so so pissed off at the things
cnn does or msnbc
and you know just watching rachel maddow
on the verge of tears when the
russiagate scandal was proven the
russiagate thing was proven false she
was almost crying i think i i totally
understand why so many people were were
laughing and so happy to see that pain
schadenfreude to see these evil people
lie for now now i've been doing it
forever you know but it's gotten so bad
and for the the nerve of these people to
to just keep pushing the lies like uh
cuomo chris cuomo
faked being in quarantine
we all know it and they still keep lying
what pisses me off is that people keep
falling for it well i didn't fall for
this when you look at this picture of
these dudes i see airbrushed photography
really bright light coming from the left
shadow on the right to make him give
this angelic glow
it just it just oozes with with crap
well it's so actually that's jake tapper
on the left right yeah i feel really sad
about jake tapper because i remember
during the obama years he confronted i
want to say jake
what he was the least bad yeah he
confronted jay carney i think it was
about the kill list about obama's kill
list and he was really forceful about it
i think it's probably still on youtube
and then fast forward to the trump years
and he's having a tantrum meltdown
because donald trump didn't thank john
mccain in the ndaa spending bill are you
going to talk about indefinite detention
built into that bill you're going to
talk about the billions of dollars spent
on empire no no he's going to thank john
mccain for his service because donald
trump didn't and it's just so sad to
watch i wonder about that too like you
know we get wrapped up in so much this
culture we're stuff even talking about
cnn i wonder if that's what keeps us
safe on youtube because if we started
talking about the ndaa and definite
detention provision and obama and biden
killing kids and the corruption and we
start getting deep on foreign policy i
bet then they would nuke us yeah that
would be an example of not playing ball
right now we're actually playing tennis
with cnn talking about how bad they are
we're keeping them prescient but uh and
relevant by talking about them yeah but
i do wonder like who do they think this
is for like benefit of the doubt they
just have poor strategy and they think
that they're going to actually reach
people mired in disinformation like
benefit of the doubt they're really
doing they think they're being really
honorable journalists and they're trying
to stop the spread of misinformation but
in reality who's going to watch this
it's people who already agree with them
so that kind of just serves intentional
or not to deepen the divide and deepen
the polarization where the people
watching the show can be like ah look at
those idiots look how stupid they are
that they would believe that i'm better
than them they're other than me and all
that really does is perpetuate the
division that's already so severe
can you tell me the difference between
misinformation and disinformation one is
accidental one's intentional yeah what's
intentional offhand misinformation is
when people are just wrong and
disinformative i may have used that
incorrectly or interchangeably but yeah
i'm looking at this digital digital
forensic research lab from the atlantic
council and they're uh they're out to
study disinformation and expose
falsehoods intentional propaganda
that's what we were doing intentional
propaganda disinformation that's the
cia's main
main
operator operation modus operandi is
disinformation right and what's so funny
is with the anti-media for example it
was our strategy to as often as possible
cite mainstream news just what are you
gonna say we're quoting you and if you
dig into a lot of those mainstream
articles the information is there they
just don't lead with it they don't
emphasize it it's you know it's a byline
or a scrolling marquee on it on a tv
channel but
it's the most of that information is out
there the new york times was reporting
on obama's killers during the obama
years it's not that they're not covering
it it's just it's not propped up and
blasted and it's not forced into the the
biggest narrative that they're pushing
let me ask you guys a question don't
look at the screen
all right we'll start with uh with you
carrie cnn 11 p.m slot
how many viewers in the key demo do you
think don lemon got
what's the key demo 25 to 54.
i mean
major cable network cnn they're in
hotels how many key demo viewers you
think they would get
generously
75 000 i don't know what you're cheating
because that's that's 74. oh is it
really knowing it's not nice yeah i
didn't look i swear that's wonderful
msnbc 11th hour how many how many how
many things they got in the key demo
fifty thousand eight thousand eighty
five thousand eighty and then gut felt
on fox news
200. 343 000.
so if you if you look at their ratings
in general with the older crowd it's a
bit higher i think it's uh 347 000. when
you when you go to like nine p.m
it's a hundred and sixty nine thousand
in the key demo so it's a little bit
better than that 10 p.m 134 but hannity
is getting half a million carlson's
getting 559 000. the interesting thing
is this is what's crazy to me is
our numbers are not too far off from
that now that's in one hour
for us in about an hour we are getting
like a hundred and fifty to two hundred
thousand key demo viewers
this show is rivaling the likes of cnn
i just want to say like be optimistic
yeah we we are winning how many
interactions does cnn get zero because
that's they're not built for it it's an
old media form right and how many people
are passively watching it like and how
many people are taking it seriously and
how many people are watching it just for
the lows and just for the ridiculousness
how many people are trapped in an
airport i mean i'm not another hotel no
no hotel hotel lobbies because the
airport thing ended they canceled that
contract do smart tvs measure if like
three people are watching them now have
they figured out how to do that i don't
know but i have to imagine
you know i've i've gone to i've been in
a lot of airports and whenever i would
go in they would have cnn and i don't
mean like they do these they do this
deal
where the airport tvs are played i mean
like i'll go to a lounge for like the
united lounge or the american lounge and
they would have three tvs and they'd be
playing like cnn and maybe sports and
i'd be like can you turn that off and
they'd be like yeah and they would pop
their room out and they would turn it
off and like i don't care what you put
on just change channel because that
stuff is mind-melting garbage
and you know what i did favors it's your
key demo number from one night is that
what that is
so
we we actually uh you know tim castillo
gets
we do the two-hour show and it's it's
close to like half a million in the key
demo within two hours so if we were i
don't know
after one hour it's actually like
two-thirds of the views of the first
hour and then it goes down so we're
probably getting like 250 to 300
thousand key demo viewers in one hour
and if you look at that we're we're half
of carlson we're around half of handy or
laura ingram or gutfeld which makes
sense but we're like at or or or twice
as much as what cnn and msnbc get
granted rachel maddow beats us she got
300 311 000 key demo viewers was it you
that i was shooting this tv be gone
video with a couple of years ago we were
we were literally that was a decade ago
bro well yeah well we have potato but
there's this tv be gone uh device that
literally was able to turn off every
single television me and tim went on
doing important work by literally
walking around and shutting off all the
corporate media that was in times square
in restaurants in of course uh you know
major bars and entertainment areas they
got tents a couple times when i had that
with me on other occasions when we
weren't filming but uh we literally made
a video of like we gotta save people and
we're gonna use this device by turning
off tvs everywhere we actually we
accidentally turned off a menu for pizza
restaurant i remember that yeah because
when you press it it just automatically
gives all the tv codes uh signals all at
once and turns it all off but seriously
turn off the programming turn off the
conditioning watching cnn it's
nauseating
it raises your blood pressure it's
nothing but but constant low vibrational
fear
nonsense crap and it really doesn't
serve you in any way shape or form it
doesn't keep you informed it does the
opposite of that it makes you uh
misinformed about what's really
happening in this world i can't remember
what we were talking about with this but
you go to youtube and you search for a
news story like if
you're not going to get a youtuber
you're going to get cnn cbs the crazy
thing is if you search for something on
youtube
that might not be related to news
you'll get news
you search for anything political and
instead of getting information from like
an educational source you'll get cnn
you'll get cbs or pbs it's just weird
and it's fascinating too because their
numbers aren't that great even getting
prioritized by these big tech platforms
i remember facebook had a whole program
it must have been 2015-16 to prop up
reliable news sources and it was like
fox news cnn msnbc and even then they
still weren't getting the engagement and
the reach and the shares that people
like the engine that the anti-media was
getting not just us but a lot of
independent news organizations and that
was being not only having huge
followings but also being propped up by
these institutions anderson cooper mr
vanderbilt had a special deal with
facebook that literally was making sure
that they had facebook exclusive content
available to everyone shoving it down
their throats shoving it down their
algorithms and they were playing it in
my news feed everyone's news feed and
they stopped that partnership because no
one was watching it no one wants to
watch uh deep state television no one
wants to to watch something that
disrespects their intellect in the basic
understanding of human life and uh i i
remember there used to be a time a few
years ago where i would just have cnn on
because they weren't as sensationalistic
they weren't as bombastic they weren't
as crazy but still back then even a few
years ago i would have it on because
they would have you know good breaking
news coverage and i would i was
monitoring the news and it was somewhat
okay still kind of uh low vibrational
but not as bad now i literally feel sick
watching them i i literally feel
nauseous and i'm like i can't this is
this is this is absolutely uh a
weaponized
infotainment that's meant to hurt people
in so many extensive ways
um terrain theory of disease luke your
your body is mirroring the neurons of
the people you're watching so when you
watch one like brian stelter and he's
all stressed out and hates his life
that you're gonna start your body is
gonna start mimicking that behavior of
stress maybe not necessarily but that's
the theory of like terrain theory of
disease is involved with that and mirror
neurons and things like that i think
absolutely part of if you hear someone
sniffling on the phone when you're
talking to him it might actually make
you sniffle you know because you start
or yawning yawning is another example of
it let's watch out what you expose your
brain to let's do a hard segue
we'll talk about what's going on with
the truckers we got the story from
global news
crossing delayed monday at manitoba u.s
border as truckers protest vaccine
mandate have you guys seen this a bunch
of truckers blocked both directions the
canadian u.s border so that it was it
was it was difficult to enter and
difficult to leave because canada is
going to be imposing a vaccine mandate
where if you are a us citizen a trucker
you can't enter canada unless you're
vaccinated and if you're a canadian
trucker and you enter and you're not
vaccinated you have to quarantine so
naturally people are protesting and
at a time when there's already shortages
at a time when the policies in this
regard have already failed
it seems like i'm sorry man i know
people don't like hearing it but
it's almost intentional gutting of the
system because you know truckers aren't
going to go for this and you know
without them you won't get food so why
do it it's like they're trying to
destroy the economy on purpose it's like
they're trying to have something like a
great reset it's like they're trying to
destroy the current system that we're
living under in order to reboun rebuild
back a new one that works in their favor
and i i think chaos is the name of the
game i think that's what they're trying
to achieve there's always this kind of
prevailing idea of order out of chaos
and if you look at a lot of the moves
that governments have been making
throughout human history those are the
moves that they're making they create
chaos they thrive off that situation
they create the problem they have a
reaction that they know is going to be
created by it and of course then they
bring in the solution which works in
their favor because there's no
explanation this is not based on any why
are they doing this there's no science
there's no data there's no information
saying that this is going to help anyone
except destroy the economy we got the
story from tim cast federal government
moves forward with program that permits
teens to become truck drivers
the trucking industry is in need of of
an estimated 80 000 drivers so what's
the plan teenagers are more likely to
get the vac so the truckers who quit
over the vacuum mandate will be replaced
by teenagers is that is that what's
happening
i i got to say man look i feel like a
chicken in a chicken coop i got no idea
what their plan is it doesn't make sense
people are taking dumps in their water
and then claiming they're not and i'm
just like what you know let me let me
just just say people underestimate how
clown clowned out the clown world is
there's a video i tweeted about about
you know some some person saying
some their pronouns are clown and clown
self and i'm like yeah that about
explains it yeah that's right you know
what think about the the bombing of uh
london you brought this up last week uh
during the blitzkrieg oh wrong micro
brought it up yeah mike rowe brought
this up and that after a few days of
bombing they just climbed out of the
basement and got back to life and as
normal because you have no other choice
it was a real emergency you had to take
back control of your life this isn't
okay i don't want to step out i don't
want to say something i regret later but
it's this is not the bombing of of
london what we're going through right
now people are not getting their bodies
exploded and running for their life
so
is this something is this a real
emergency rat utopian i'm sorry you
compare it to war it's not not like that
not like the rat hope experiment
they put us under lockdown everyone
panics begins to go nuts then they take
us out dry us off put him back put us
back in and then we swim for 60 hours if
this was a real emergency we wouldn't be
waiting for authority to give us the
go-ahead well to play devil's advocate
and i'm not saying that this is what i
believe i'm just saying like is there
any other reason why they would be doing
this i absolutely believe there are
people in power who
are doing this for control for authority
but i'm wondering like what about aren't
there people in positions of power who
genuinely believe it themselves and are
just as caught as people watching msnbc
and like genuinely believe that this is
going to work like through their
arrogance and their certainty about
their version of reality they think that
if they do this they are going to get
people to get vaccinated i'm not saying
it's right but is it possible that it's
not always sinister it's not always
nefarious and manipulative it's actually
just people who are also programmed well
then we got a problem because there's a
zombie horde taking over and they're
marching through the streets they're
unable to tell you know what it is
i i explained this of jack dorsey
he creates twitter
twitter creates fertile uh ground for
the refuse of the far left broken
ideologies
jack dorsey having created twitter and
now following people who are trapped in
the sewer of twitter he begins drinking
his own refuse and believing his own
insanity and then his opinions get
shaped thinking this is reality when in
reality he made a big toilet a big
toilet for people to take dumps into
with their garbage ideas he absorbs
those garbage ideas thinks they're real
so what we have is there's there's a
possibility that there is a cabal of
powerful individuals who are pulling the
strings with big corporate donations
with lobbying and things like that i
think that's true obviously to a certain
extent but it's entirely possible that
crackpot idiots on cnn follow other
crackpot idiots and they recycle
information playing and get a big game
of telephone and then here's what
happens somebody writes an article and
they're like i need clicks so they're
like i think trump is a fascist so trump
is trump be behaving like a fascist
print
then their friend following them sees it
and they go did you read that article
talking about trump acting like a
fascist you know it's pretty fascistic
so then this guy then writes an article
saying trump is a fascist then his
friend sees it and says whoa trump is is
like the fascists he's like mussolini
then he writes trump is like mussolini
then someone sees and says no not like
muslim he's like hitler then they're
right trump is like hitler then someone
else says like trump trump is as bad as
hitler and then someone goes he's worse
they're all just basically swimming in a
circle of their own sewage exciting
themselves and then after a a week of
telephone they're all screaming that
trump is the re-emergence of hitler and
it's like yo you guys are nuts calm down
stop drinking each other's waste and
just actually get out there and talk to
real people they don't do it so now
they're screaming bill maher brings it
up that democrats were polled and they
were asked what the likelihood was
percentage-wise of needing
hospitalization if you get covered and
they said 50
and he was like what
republicans and independent voters got
it right 5
but these are people who believe each
other hyping each other up constantly
one-upping garbage fake news until
they're like locked the whole country
down burnt to the ground otherwise
everyone dies they are running around
screaming the sky is falling and for
some reason we've been listening to them
and arguing with them instead of just
excising them from political discourse
and saying do whatever you want i'll be
over here living i disagree with both of
you guys surprise surprise i believe
it's a conspiracy because for for this
kind of ignorance to to be perpetrated
right i'm not saying it's not i might be
wrong but but for this type of policy to
be implemented because of popular
support people have to say to themselves
the vaccine mandates worked so great
that we have to implement more vaccine
mandates and i think it's pretty clear
to the average person paying attention
that they absolutely didn't i mean
there's even trudeau and fauci coming
out on record saying that these mandates
these vaccine mandates aren't about
health they're about convincing other
people to take the shot so this kind of
fervent
policy making that clearly is disrupting
the economy clearly is going to have
negative effects when already the store
shelves are barren in some places when
already the supply chain has been
disrupted asking for more supply chain
disruptions is literally creating chaos
so i'm sticking to what i personally
believe and that's my personal feeling
and i could be wrong because i don't
think it's idiots leading the herd i
think it's uh you know a few
powerful people creating the the idiots
that are bringing them along but there's
not a lot of them uh still when it comes
to the bigger official story of kovid
which is breaking let's make a short
film
a zombie apocalypse happens and it's
like it starts off very much like a
zombie movie it's like run you know get
the shotgun oh jesus zombies are coming
and then we'll have ian be like you know
i was listening to what they were saying
i kind of agree i'm going to go join
them and we're like no ian you want to
go talk to him i'll i'll be back
oh you think i should just full on just
go join them like it kind of makes sense
i'll come in in the middle of the night
i'll wake you up tim i've been listening
to the zombies they've been telling me
i don't have to make any tough decisions
no no you got to be like he's here
they've been saying brains so much i
kind of wonder if eating brains does
make sense
i think we should consider like ian
you're turning into one of them and they
don't actually bite you to make you a
zombie you just listen to them enough
and then you start believing brains
listening to it on repeat on youtube too
all the zombies they actually aren't
infected with anything they're just all
scared to step out of line because the
other zombies will attack them if they
act like they're not zombies so it's
actually a horde of people pretending to
be zombies that's mass formation
psychosis that is that would be actually
a funny little skit to do
where it's just like a bunch of people
who are like i'm a zombie and no one
dare step out of line and then one guy
goes
wait a minute you guys aren't actually
zombies and they're like brains and they
attack them and they're all looking
around like oh i'm a zombie
oh i got a question for you guys justin
trudeau is he evil mastermind or is he
fool that's being provoked by the evil
mastermind he seems like a mastermind to
me i don't know how blatantly he's just
willing to say like yeah we're gonna
violate your rights we don't
and maybe he's just so far gone that he
thinks that's acceptable because i know
there are a lot of people who feel that
way but he was dealing arms to the
saudis for years and it's been well
documented how their human rights track
record and what they do in yemen and he
had no problem arming them yeah he's
true and true and authoritarian he's
he's a communist he loves centralization
he was literally cheerleading china
because of the way that they run their
economy you know
china literally destroys human rights
for their economy and this is something
that trudeau openly praises and looks up
to so i i wouldn't even say mastermind
or puppet i would say sociopath that's
been put in a position of power that's
playing out the agenda of the world
economic forum of the davos group and
it's reading the handbook and following
every single procedure that they asked
him to follow i don't know his dad but
his dad was the prime minister before
him fidel castro
was his dad notoriously authoritarian or
people people keep posting photos of him
next to fedex he looks like fidel castro
i'm not gonna hold it again i do look
like putin
if if putin bill maher and julian
assange had a love child i would pop out
but that's a different story but uh i
don't think i'm related to putin who
knows uh but my i do i don't think you
are but
[Laughter]
this would explain why he's an
authoritarian communist because you know
fedex is an authoritarian communist
there's like a a long lost autobiography
from putin where he talks about how he
once ventured to poland in the mid mid
80s
and had an affair with luke and he's
like i am your father
well i was a part of the resistance
against the soviet union so when putin
was a kgb agent my family was going up
against the communists a part of the
salidernos movement in northern poland
and dinzing
what if there was like a whirlwind
affair where vladimir is like i cannot
be with you it is forbidden so there
could be a star wars movie here with me
being on opposing sides and then my
family helping take down the soviet
union which of course is the evil empire
which putin was a kgb agent of that is
possible i think the better story is
that putin had a series of clones made
when he was in the kgb and like they
were supposed to be destroyed yeah and
and and luke is programmed to be
activated as a sleeper agent for the
soviet union
we'll make a clone with different
mindsets yeah one is very very anarchist
this is very important news we're
discussing right now yeah that's very
important
there are a lot of people who i see
comments when they're saying you know
it's too pessimistic to talk about
things falling apart
and i'm like what should we talk about
now i i mean that sincerely like uh i
think watching the media collapse is not
bad news i think it's a good thing i
find that watching cnn um trying to
think your way out of the psychosis
doesn't work it's like no thought is the
way to to get away from that stuff which
is why i usually turn up the tv if it
looks step outside or something if you
turn the tv off
and go outside and ignore the mainstream
media and just say like tend to your
goats or chickens for a week when you
turn the tv on it'll be like it'll be
like watching saturn there'll be a
different planet you'll be like what
what are they talking about because the
news changes so rapidly these days like
like you if you listen to dr fauci this
i mentioned this you know
a while back he'll come out and he'll be
like you don't need to be wearing two
masks but then three days later he's
like you should be wearing two masks and
then you get one person who watched one
story
and then didn't see the update and the
other person who sees the update and now
they're arguing online about who's right
and who's wrong and it's like yo
i bet you could spend seven days away
and miss this news cycle changing three
times and come back and not even know it
changed yeah and have nothing to argue
about well i i think no no i think it'll
be like you know fauci will come out i
mean joe biden comes out joe biden said
that the vaccines would stop the spread
of the pandemic yeah that's not what
they're saying now yeah so if you were
someone who passively watched the news
and heard biden say that you'd be like
oh how about that today you turn the
news on and they're saying something
totally different you'd be like what did
i like go into the twilight zone or
something do these people forget do they
have amnesia that's the funniest thing
when there are there are people
on twitter tweeting at me being like uh
duh the the vaccines do x and i'm like
that's not what joe biden or
or or the cdc director said three months
ago i understand science changes
but isn't it a bit too rapid because if
it is changing this rapidly then there's
no plan and it's very likely to change
again yeah you're right sorry no go
ahead okay i'll just go really quickly
you have to be traumatized to be believe
the official story and there's a lot of
people who are traumatized that the
corporate media and the politicians
scare the crap out of every single day
and that's the only way that they could
get them in a state that's irrational
not paying attention and has them going
along with the big overlord state saying
we will protect you when of course
they're doing the complete opposite of
that sorry go ahead no i was just going
to say it's like okay yes science does
change but it would go a very long way
if the people who are constantly
changing the opinions could just
acknowledge oh okay well it changed it's
wrong and you don't see that you see
people getting gaslit and people being
blamed as and being shamed for
questioning things when it's always
changing like how can you not have a
healthy level of skepticism you're
allowed to to notice that there are
discrepancies and sure okay science may
explain that but if you could just drop
the arrogance and the hubris about it i
think they would have a lot better
chance of communicating with people they
think need to hear it what wasn't our
good friend wasn't it our good friend
ethan klein who said you don't even need
to think right
didn't he say yeah yeah that's why he
said just go to the government's website
you don't even need to think do what the
government tells you
i mean i kind of read history books when
i was growing up
you don't do that in fact
we were always told that descent was
patriotic in this country now you have
this massive group of people who are
like
descent is can is insurrection is wrong
don't do it just do what you're told
this is the funny thing about the
vaccine mandates when they say the
vaccine mandates work but new york is
experiencing a major surge in covet
cases what they're really saying is the
vaccines force people to get uh
vaccinated the mandates do yeah i'm
sorry sorry the mandates
work
and what they mean is it's forcing
people to get it
i thought they meant or initially and i
probably shouldn't assume this that it
was going to actually stem the spread
because joe biden said that right now
that's not the case it's to reduce the
severity and i'm like well the hospitals
are overloaded fact and there's
record-breaking amounts of covet also a
fact tons of people are getting i mean
glenn beck had it recently mike rowe
mentioned he had it over christmas i
think crowder had it i could be wrong
yeah he did everybody's getting it
so
now they're saying well it was never
supposed to stop the spread was supposed
to reduce the severity of symptoms and
i'm like you said joe biden actually
said that it would you know it would all
be over they actually said several times
once everyone gets vaccinated you don't
gotta wear masks and the pandemic will
end and it's not ending now i think it's
fair to say okay maybe they got it wrong
but at a certain point they should be
like it's probably gonna change we don't
know for sure but everyone's so sure of
themselves yeah they didn't know that
had waning immunity so how did they know
anything else surrounding this very
specifically yeah yeah
exactly the same thing pretty much uh
but but the official story has changed
so many times that these bureaucrats
have flip-flopped so many times it's
difficult to even understand where we're
at right now and i think the strategy
that they're implementing right now is
let's just spin people around so they
get confused that don't know what's
going on and it's all going to be scary
unless you just obey us that's that's
the policy that they have implemented
because
you know it's only going to be a certain
time now where people are going to be
like okay i'm going to stop spinning now
i'm going to start paying attention to
what's going on here because we've been
bamboozled we've been we've been lied to
and i think this larger mass awakening
is happening and it's going to have some
very severe effects on our society and
our political system this is why the
democrats are giving up kovid in my
opinion right before this upcoming
election because they can't win with
this policy that has destroyed people's
lives and only enriched the billionaire
class they can't i don't i don't think
people want to to accept that when i say
not everybody just there are some people
who don't accept when i say that the
country is breaking apart or that states
are breaking apart i don't see that as a
bad thing i mean luke brought up
peaceful divorce a while ago michael
malus has talked about it so hawaii
recently announced that you need a
booster shot to enter the state
california wants to double their taxes
so they can pay for universal health
care well obviously california will
struggle to make that work i mean
they're going to require heavy subsidy
rich people are going to walk out of the
state then they're going to try and tax
them 10 years after the fact that's one
thing they announced and then you're
going to see a bunch of poor people
flood into the state to get free health
care clearly doesn't work but hey
let people go to the state they want
with the laws they want people will
leave if there ends up being some kind
of fracturing of this country it means
yo i'm going to go to west virginia i'm
gonna have all my guns i'll be very
pleased and happy and then the people
who don't like guns and want them banned
can go to california and then they can
have free health care what's the problem
how is that a bad thing what about
artillery
all of it artillery can fire across
state lines
what if it's banned in one state but
it's legal in the other state yeah
that's too bad for the state that banned
it i guess
that sounds like an arms race
whatever yeah
yeah i don't know
you don't remember
sometimes thomas massey tweeted
what piece of second amendment
legislation should we should we push if
we take control and everyone was like
abolish the atf repeal the nfa and i'm
like yes those things i i went further
and i said man gun mandates if you want
to go out to a diner you got to have
proof of gun and you've got to be able
to show that's loaded
proof of gun
so you'll walk up to the diner and
they'll be like we have a gun mandate in
this city if you want to come in you
have to be armed and you'll be like oh
i've got my 1911 right here i got my
proof on my right i've got a revolver
let me show you my 38 or whatever and uh
you can walk in maybe with a right you
got to have a gun gun mandates mandatory
gun ownership anyway speaking about this
specific topic that we were just talking
about
it's also important to note that the
england is looking at getting rid of
their their health pass they're looking
to get rid of their vaccine passport
system which soon will be implemented
this is a huge shift in the narrative as
of course there's major scientific
studies there's a lot of information
coming out that clearly is disrupting
this entire official story of what
they've been telling us from the very
beginning so this whole narrative is
collapsing this there's a lot of
important uh reasons to be extremely
optimistic i've been talking about this
weeks ago i'm saying with this latest uh
variant there's a big probability even
according to the world health
organization that announced that this is
going to be the end of covid potentially
in 2022 so there's a lot of mainline
institutions there's a lot of mainline
doctors talking about what we were
talking months ago and there's this uh
meme going around that i tweeted that
specifically so shows you know the
talking points that this uh
administration and that these
authorities had from the very beginning
you die but you go to heaven that said
95 protection in may june 70 protection
70 protection august no protection but
reduces spread september doesn't reduce
spread but reduces severity october
doesn't reduce severity but reduces
hospitalizations november doesn't reduce
hospitalizations but you aren't going to
die and then december you die but you go
to heaven so so that's a good one that
you know that's essentially it's a joke
youtube
down everyone can go talk to their
doctors yeah that's right again not a
medical doctor not here giving you any
kind of medical advice we're not here to
do that we're here to point out that
that there's elements of people making
fun of of what we've been told and and
exaggerating it because it's already
been exaggerated to such an extensive
level that it's hard for people to pay
attention to even what's going on yeah
you said that in 2022 we might see the
end of covet according to what the world
health organization i would point out
that maybe not the end of covid the end
of covet hysteria but that the virus
itself i've heard that it's supposedly
will be endemic meaning that we're just
going to live with the thing the
coronavirus that's one theory out there
there's another theory that this latest
variant is spreading so fast that it's
going to create natural immunity
it's less severe less people are going
to end up in the hospital so all
everyone's going to get it because of
how fast it spreads to everyone and then
essentially it will kind of die out and
phase out from here because everyone
will have immunity
and
this goes but when you look at
coronaviruses there's usually a specific
trend of how they kind of operate of how
they infect people and how they stop
infecting people based on those
mutations so if we're following the
basic procedures of how previous
coronavirus sars and mers have affected
the world it's it's logical to believe
that this is going to happen here dr
fauci has a different story saying
there's going to be another variant
that's going to be really bad but of
course he of course has an invested
interest in keeping the storyline going
because his entire career is
made on the severity of this sickness so
obviously as a conflict of interest
again these are some of the debates
happening within the scientific
community that i think are extremely
important right now and i think are
important to pay attention to because if
this is the case there's going to be
some significant political changes in
our society when we come to the end of
this and people feel bamboozled and lied
to about everything so this this is
something that we need to understand
politically socially and economically
because the effects of this are going to
be with us for years to come after this
i hope that we can as a species learn to
kind of live maybe in a more coherent
manner with viruses in general i just
looked it up 380 trillion viruses inside
of the human body 380 trillion
uh how many of those are hurting us
hardly any of them if any of them we
they live in symbiosis with us that's
the point
so i i don't see why that can't happen
with corona in fact it looks like you're
on track as you see the different
variants appear the most successful
viruses you don't even know you have
yeah they they sit in your body they do
virus stuff but they don't cause enough
problems for you to actually care about
it i would imagine some of them help you
i got to go deeper into it or get a
viral just on the show or something
there's that one parasite that makes you
love cats oh yes
toxoplasmosis yes which a lot of people
in brazil have there's a fascinating
video of rogan talking to alex jones
about it and they go off i don't know if
that video clip is still on on youtube
but it is terrifying to find out about
uh the effects of taxoplasmosis well it
makes people some people get
schizophrenia it literally creates the
crazy cat lady syndrome like the the the
basic stereotypical understanding of a
crazy cat lady obsessive loving of her
cats this is something that of course
cats have as a
as a mechanism for their survival when
they kind of have this virus that's in
poop that makes rats love them so
there's elements of this according to
some medical studies highlighting how
their similar effects on the human brain
that cause women and men to be impulsive
causes them to also be affected by this
in a very negative state but again
viruses are something that we have been
dealing with from the beginning of
humanity it's something that of course
is not going away and i i think there's
a lot of important learning lessons from
everything that happened within the last
two years that we should really uh
learn from and not repeat those mistakes
that were made i remember when i was
growing up i had a lot of important
learning lessons
like what was the most important one the
impossible learning lesson yes oh just
you know reading about the history of
world war ii learning lessons were
really important for me as a kid
did you experience learning lessons
yeah i learned a lot of lessons learning
lessons another leukism
it's a you didn't even know it was a
lukeism that's why i said no and it's a
learning lesson
you have a lesson and you learn from it
i like it listen i'm going to make up
all the words i want to make up okay it
makes sense you guys know exactly what
i'm saying and uh i might even make my
own learning lessons about this
well speaking of learning lessons if
we're going to move on i just want to
say before that i know i think this all
started because of a comment that said
it's really it's cynical to talk about
how everything's falling apart but
speaking of lessons and history i just
want to point out i i do see how it can
sound cynical and it can often be
depressing and there is often a sense of
hopelessness but if you do look at
history regimes fall people resist like
i'm sure there are some exceptions to
this i want to say always but the like
the grand scheme of history and all of
the empires and all of the
authoritarians who've ruled over people
eventually it falls all empires collapse
that i think so i know china's still
going pretty strong but how long have
they actually been in power yes it's
true but have they had mind control
technology
and artificial intelligence which is
going to be the next nuclear weapon a
lot of arguments against uh anarchists
and mass surveillance yep a lot of argue
our arguments against anarchists and the
second amendment is are you going to
allow people to have nuclear weapons
well literally there's private
individuals and corporations creating
weapons that are even far more superior
and more powerful than nuclear weapons
that specifically is artificial
intelligence and that's happening right
now with collusion of the state let me
ask you what's scarier for you
the fact that certain states have
nuclear bombs warheads or the fact that
private unaccountable individuals can
post your web browser history
hmm
i mean i got a message i'm not worried
about nuclear war
you know what i mean i'm honestly not
super scared about uh i don't like the
spying or anything but i'm sure there's
a lot of people who are like you know
look people cheating on their wives is a
good example
yeah facebook knows if you're cheating
on your wife young women who are
pregnant don't want their parents to
find out of their boyfriends to find out
big tech knows all of that and there was
even wasn't it like the nsa were tubanet
to pick private phones nsa agents were
caught
lube and tubenet to people's private
photos that they were sharing with their
loved ones unsuspectingly it's not like
they put published it it was private
messages between loved ones that the nsa
intercepted and decided to entertain
themselves with in many unspeakable ways
family-friendly show you get the gist of
whatever two minutes how did they get
caught did someone kick the door walked
in and they're like what i don't
remember the exact details of this but
this was a mainline like story even
before edward snowden came out saying
hey the nsa are
doing this this is how they caught tsa
agents also have an extremely horrible
record of abusing their power with
individuals that they have to engage
with and act with but
i think you were talking about a lot of
those stories carrie when you were
working in alternative media
specifically the stories that have been
significantly underplayed but are
significant to our way of life which one
was the do you think in your opinion one
of the most kind of egregious ones when
it comes to government abuse of power uh
abusive power in general or surveillance
both
well i mean obviously what snowden
cracked open with all of his with his
i don't want to say leaks because he was
so careful about releasing it but
nonetheless i'm actually looking it up
and apparently it was snowden who said
that that the nsa would intercept nude
pics yes he said that he confirmed it
but there was even before that i was
even before
mainline articles talking about this
uh which um
again is just i mean imagine imagine
having a private moment where you were
loved on and then there's fat cat
bureaucrats
becky's
siffening through all your private most
intimate moments and they're using it
for their own uh bastardized way back
let's uh let's
let's do uh one more one more segment we
got the story from fortune
fauci says there are five stages of the
coveted pandemic and we are still in
phase one oh no
i don't know what else you want me to
say guys you know that said he says the
first phase of the pandemic or the truly
pandemic according to is where the world
is really very negatively impacted the
following four steps are deceleration
control elimination and finally
eradication
here are the characteristics blah blah
blah okay so he's basically saying get
ready it's not going to end he's like
everything that that that
my career is based on is going to be
around for a while just so you know
with the covet pandemic goes away fauci
goes away and he knows it he's you i've
never heard of the guy until this thing
appeared i mean people in the 80s knew
who he was i guess yeah well i'm just
like i look at this and it's like
all this says to me is that the
government failed despite all of their
efforts and all of their claims of
certainty that they knew exactly what
they what to do to fix it here we are
and this is just like an advertisement
against government policy to me to see
this guy just saying nope this is as far
as we've gotten and despite all of this
no that we're still on stage it's been
two years
and we're still in stage one it's two
weeks give us more power you can trust
it two weeks to slow the spread but this
this there's some good news here there's
some really good news here because this
is dr fauci saying it the guy flip-flops
and is wrong on almost everything which
means he's probably wrong about this as
well which means we're probably closer
to the end than the actual starting
point but before again fauci a lot of
invested interest he's one of the few
bureaucrats that actually makes more
money from his side hustles than he does
from his government job his government
job pays him more than any other
bureaucrat in washington dc so he's
making a lot of money there was recent
financial uh
transactions that were released showing
that he has at least 10 million dollars
in assets and this is a man who's been
working for the government almost his
entire life where has those millions of
dollars come from well of course those
are important questions that a lot of
people should be asking he has a lot of
connections to a lot of very powerful
individuals and of course as we know
everything that the united states has
been involved in has been a big business
against the american people but how do
you see this kind of unfolding uh carrie
how do you see this covet landscape this
this dr fauci landscape moving from this
particular moment in time
honestly i i mean it's just my opinion i
thought hillary clinton was gonna win in
2016. so you know take it for what it's
worth but it's being from los angeles
and having spent a lot of the pandemic
there i think it's going to be very
difficult for the federal government
even for cal state governments local
governments to keep enforcing this
because people are burned out and los
angeles was one of the most compliant
places in the country as far as i could
tell and as policy-wise and just the
people in general but even like at this
point there are people are they can't do
it anymore they're sick of it even
people who got vaccinated and now they
feel that they were misled i don't want
to say lied to because sure the science
changed but there are people who feel
that even though they followed all of
these protocols they followed all the
policies they obeyed they did what they
were told to be good people and still it
hasn't been resolved i'm telling you los
angeles is such a liberal place and i
left for six weeks in the fall and i
came back and there was way less
compliance like there were people in
stores not wearing masks and nobody said
anything whereas before i left that you
didn't see that that wasn't a thing and
i know that people are burned out
because of what i'm seeing in los
angeles where it's heavily liberal and
people really had good intentions about
stopping this part of the pandemic and
doing everything they could to end it i
have a friend who got vaccinated and
now he's being told well actually he
doesn't work you have to get another and
he's not doing it because he felt he did
it for the sake of doing his part
stopping the spread bill marshall the
same thing you know took one for the
team and now he's they're not going to
convince him to do it again but the
problem is if you trust the science and
if the official narrative is the
statements from the cdc and all that is
you need to get your booster then who
are you to to to you know challenge the
system if you're doing your part why
would you stop now now i will always
stress
you know get your advice from trusted
medical professionals don't look at me
about it but i will add
my one of my favorite memes is fauci as
vader saying i have altered the science
pray i don't alter it further yeah
dude the point of this is never to
eradicate the virus from the day one it
was to stop the slow the spread in 15
days so that we don't overload the
hospitals end of story let the thing run
its course don't overload the hospitals
that was the plan not this five point
thing where number five is eradication
of the virus this isn't polio
right and it's weird because i i
remember that talking point it was we
have to not overwhelm hospitals and i'm
looking at this just as i'm looking at
this article and it's like you guys have
had two years and you haven't been able
to get hospitals the resources they need
and i'm still supposed to take your
advice and listen do not even advise
commands and just obey your commands
when you couldn't even solve the initial
problem that all this was for and you've
had all this time i think
you know one thing i think i feel like
we should probably mention more though
with all of this is as much as
policy-wise i think opposition's very
clear it's very libertarian
or or even anarchic for you guys
i also think it's important to point out
there's probably really serious
long-term health effects for covet that
aren't even being picked up right now
and so i say this because
you know it's now been several months
for us but i still i still feel a
presence from having kovac i can't feel
it in my back from time to time yeah
still here i can tell i'm just immune
having immunity to it now well i i think
i i think we're all over i think we're
past it but people get scarring in their
lungs and i think
you've got on the left a complete
overhyping of everything panic non-stop
panic you have many on the right who are
just like be done with it we can't you
know and i i would agree more with that
it's like look i actually i recognize
it's really bad i get it i think we
should continue to to push for
scientific breakthroughs on this stuff i
think we should also remind people
you know i'm i'm concerned about the
long-term health effects of what
covenants i eat crappy food i lose my
smell after covid i eat garlic and onion
i regain my smell it's not kovit's fault
obviously it's dietary
the point i'm trying to make is
you know i think it was uh who was it
was it was uh um somebody tweeted don't
underestimate it it was a conservative
we have had in the show saying like it's
really it is really really bad don't let
anyone tell you otherwise and i think
that's important i still can't taste or
smell really yeah try dosing yourself
with onion and garlic yeah there there's
a butt so but but but i'll put it this
way i just don't want to get lost in
being upset about policy right to
make it seem like we would downplay the
like the sickness yeah because right we
talk about how you you probably probably
won't be hospitalized you'll probably
get better but there are long-term
effects and i think that's a fair point
to me and i think that's what's so
frustrating for some people at least
like someone like me like i took it
seriously i was considerate of other
people and yet i'm still thrown into
this category of just a crazy q and on
right-wing nazi trump supporter when in
fact like i've never said that covet
wasn't serious it's not going to be as
serious for some people as others i had
covert of spine it was pretty mild i
lost my sense of smell but other than
that yeah i was really tired and my
fever never went above 99. so like
people have different responses it's not
to say that not that i'm not saying that
everybody is gonna be fine but some
people are gonna have a terrible time
and it's important to be considerate of
others the opposition is to these
top-down mandates that even if they did
work i wouldn't support them because
their mandates but add on that they're
not even effective and i think that's
where so much of the frustration comes
from the answer just really quickly is
personal responsibility if you're
vulnerable you should take extra
measures to protect yourself this is why
i always been talking about terrain
therapy early treatment something that
of course
you could be doing this should be a big
wake-up call to a lot of people saying
hey i'm going to take my life my health
into my own hands and i'm going to make
sure that i'm the best healthiest
version of myself because there is
something and we never underplayed it we
always took it seriously we were
affected by it and it's important to
understand personal responsibility
solves all of this your life is in your
hands the government shouldn't be
controlling your life because when they
do they make it usually a lot worse
that's that's really you know all it is
uh i accept the risks if i want to go
bungee jumping i'll go bungee jumping
don't ban if i want to ride my bike if i
run my bike if i want to go out in the
middle of the woods where there's an
open shooting range that's my choice
don't ban it for me and i'll even add
this because i love the response from
these twitter lefties where they're like
should we ban seat belts and i'm like yo
if you want to wear a seat belt wear a
seat belt if i don't want to wear a
seatbelt don't force me to do it exactly
i prefer to wear a seatbelt new
hampshire
new hampshire no seatbelt loss are you
serious absolutely no helmet laws either
live free or die
it's your choice as an individual the
first thing the free staters do they're
like all in favor of banning seatbelt
laws absolutely bang the gavel it's like
hallelujah thank goodness that we live
we have a place in america where we have
still some semblance of personal
responsibility in your life
your life being in in your own hands the
funniest thing i saw in new hampshire
though was it was a man a huge muscular
guy no helmet riding a big harley but
with a big mask on which is
a little ironic but i understand there's
bugs too but no but hey do your thing
man yeah that's that's his choice
what he wants to do it's it's his
personal responsibility and and i'm not
even going to judge him until he like
gets thrown off his bike and breaks his
skull and then we have to have 15 ems
workers come out and waste hospital
space to heal this dude that could have
worn a helmet
well that's too bad don't don't don't
strain my system because you're not
going to take your system yeah i'm part
of this system we all are don't strain
it because you don't want to take care
of yourself that bothers me i warned you
kerry that he was an authoritarian some
things
like god
live free but i mean if you want to live
free or die and really take that
consequence then that's a difference no
no no i think it's i think it's fair to
point out uh ian makes a good point that
there are irresponsible people who don't
take care of their themselves they don't
wear helmets they don't eat right they
get sick and then they do clutter up the
plumbing systems the medical systems
there are people who play with fire and
then jam up our fire department then
accidents will get taken care of i just
don't think the answer is forcing people
to do things yeah in a sort of nanny
state kind of way because there's no
limit to it i mean are you going to
start policing obese people from eating
cheeseburgers because they weigh down
the system and hurt the medical
institutions obviously that's an
incredulous kind of move that the big
state control
psychopaths want to have over your
existence if someone wants to win a
darwin award this might not sound like
the nicest of things let them win the
darwin award
hold on hold on
it's not even about the darwin award
it's about skydiving exactly right
riding a motorcycle even with a helmet
is very dangerous yeah should we just
say you know motorcycles are made but
the thing about seat belts is you don't
know what a car accident's like until
you get into one and if you get into one
you better have your seat belt on
because you're gonna get through yes
driving cars is extremely dangerous more
people die from that than a lot of other
causes of death in the united states but
are we going to ban driving well we
don't buy heroin from kindergarten
classes because we don't want kids to
accidentally get hooked on it you don't
want someone to accidentally we don't
like kids drive
well yeah we do they're six when they're
16 they're still considered kids
technically for sure they're gonna be
driving trucks soon where's where's the
line and and you know what i automate
them all ian with respect this is a good
point because people need to understand
our lines for what we tolerate
are they they change from person to
person like what's the what should the
drinking age be some people think it
should be 18. i've actually seen a lot
of there's a advocacy group saying it
should be 18 because they're adults and
that by making this three year gap from
1821 you actually increase the risk of
someone who lives on their own getting
alcohol poisoning and not seeking
treatment
but everybody's got a different idea of
where that appropriate line is so that's
why i always lean more towards get the
government out of it to a certain degree
unless typically when kids are involved
to a certain age like don't deal drugs
to kids but if you're an adult i think
you should be able to imbibe or partake
as you see fit the problem is
when you decide ian this guy should have
to wear a helmet because he's going to
clog up the system if he gets injured
where do we draw the line should we just
be like don't let him ride the
motorcycle dude don't let him at the
cheeseburger yeah look look no but the
hell i don't like i don't like
commercials for sugar for kids that
bothers me like tobacco industries to
sell tobacco to kids but let's let's
address the motorcycle thing right if
you think someone should have to wear a
helmet when they're on their motorcycle
why not just ban motorcycles then you
get no accidents no because i'm not
trying to prevent the accidents i'm
trying to prevent the the clog of the
system and people with helmets on will
still break their legs and arms and
could still hurt get knocked out and get
road rash and we'll still be in the
hospitals
so
my thing is hey i'll tell you what's
easier uh ian let's get real dark with
it at least if the guy's not wearing a
helmet he won't go to the hospital go to
the morgue yep right oh that so no no
but i don't always work but my point is
if your concern is clogging up the
hospitals you go in a dark place
the solution to the problem you present
isn't what you think it is forcing
someone to wear a helmet actually would
increase the likelihood they'll go to
the hospital
if you want to clear up the system this
is what happens people understand with
with ai they'll say something like we
want to create an algorithm that encoura
that creates a system where people won't
clog the hospitals and they'll just be
like okay no seat belts no helmets
everyone dies hospitals are open no we
don't want to either yeah i'm not
looking for the world peace where
everyone gets incinerated so it's quite
useful we just have to accept that
people are going to make choices about
their lives the way they want to live
happy and as long as you're not hurting
others or stealing their stuff
what's the history of seat belts it used
to be there were no seat belt laws
wasn't ralph nader a big
crusader yeah
well adding seat belt laws i think so it
was um one of the there was a company
who created the three-point seat belt
and then gave it away for free and then
i don't know if this is true so you guys
can factor me but i was told that there
were insurance companies lobbying for
seat belt laws because
it won't change the amount of accidents
but it'll reduce the amount they have to
pay out if people are wearing seat belts
so they were very big advocates for
forcing it but let's go to super chats
because we're a little bit late if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends we're gonna have a
members only podcast up at tim cast irl
around 11 or so p.m it's gonna be
fascinating it's uncensored we cuss like
sailors yes you'll love it but let's
read some super chats all right let's
see what we got
lucas parata says hey tim kestfam i
would just like to say that ian has
grown on me over the past year he
definitely has a good heart even though
graphene has taken part of it over i
think the turning point for me was when
ian used a football analogy undone
yeah i think he likes sports too what's
up
you know what graphine is
no
searching
we'll talk about it yeah maybe go deep
on the app
actually it was it was michael malus who
said you know i first didn't understand
what ian brought to the show but now i
get it
i love you michael and i'm like well
i'll say this to you ian too you know
they're the semantic arguments that's
just i feel like you kind of did away
with those yeah people don't like that
but the the comments you brought up
about authoritarianism sparks a good
conversation you brought up a good
comment about ebola we were talking
before you know ian was like if we're
opposed to the lockdowns what if it was
an ebola we just let you know it spread
and i'm like
it's an interesting point what to what
degree of severity of pandemic would we
all kind of be like okay shut it down
with kovid we're not that scared of it
democrats are so their tolerant
tolerance has been met for for me if it
was airborne ebola i'd still err on the
side of let people take the risks they
want and i'll go hide in the woods to
stay away from airborne ebola well i
think the point is more people wouldn't
want to chance it like there would i
think there would be a lot more
voluntary compliance and measures taken
because i agree the risk would be so
blatant and obvious
yeah i think a lesson i've learned from
this is you really don't have to force
people to
to take to take precautions during a
pandemic if it's real they will do it
yeah
all right let's grab some more super
chats
roberto lara says in oklahoma there's an
apprenticeship test for 18 to 20 year
olds to be truckers and drive across the
states it was in the infrastructure bill
that congress passed and on mentality
look up billy milligan so we did mention
that i'm not a trucker so i don't know
if that's a big deal or not is that
scary is that good
maybe truckers are that's awesome great
get more truckers i don't know not sure
i know there's a shortage what's the
problem exactly that they're going to
allow teenagers to drive trucks because
they need more drivers i think that's
what bothers me is that they're about to
step into automated
uh industry so that entire industries
those people 16 year olds that are
getting jobs now probably a decade
aren't going to have those jobs anymore
maybe this is time to phase out actual
human trackers and i was going to say
one of the things that we were just
looking at was the case of a 23 year old
driver who came downhill too fast and
ended up killing a few people he got
like 150 years sentence i guess they
lightened it a little bit but yeah
that's crazy but there were there were a
lot of people who commented saying they
were truckers and they agreed with the
sentencing because
you know he's responsible for that rig
and if he doesn't know how to use it he
shouldn't be drunk i could have taken
off ramps from what i heard and he chose
not to take like too much
but but the issue i guess that people
were bringing up is
if you take a job driving a truck
and you get into an accident we
understand it's an accident
but if you choose to arm yourself with a
gun
as is your right and then you
accidentally discharge it hitting people
you are still going to go to prison and
i'm like that's actually a fair point
like this guy chose to get behind the
wheel of a rig that he didn't know how
to handle and then killed people if you
don't know how to handle your weapon and
you go out hey you're responsible for
what comes out of that
out of that gun you're responsible for
what you hit when you're in a massive
truck like that yeah so it's an
interesting point because initially i
was like this makes no sense it was an
accident and then people were like
yeah but you got to understand the
responsibility that comes with having
such weight behind you and he was not
prepared for that responsibility i don't
know if life made sense but i certainly
understand the point people are making
yeah right chris stark says dirty jobs
and how it's made should be required
learning in schools so that upcoming
generations and kids and teens get a
real grasp on how things work also bring
back civics and acts social studies
micro didn't voice how it's made did he
or or did he i think that's his new show
no yeah that is his new show that's a
show where he goes around and how it's
made no no how it's made is like today
on how it's made bubble gum and then it
shows the machine no you didn't voice
that one yeah he didn't yes yes yes yes
yes yes your voicemail called like that's
how it works or something oh okay he has
a show that's uh
i gotta tell you man one of the greatest
shows ever made is how it's made
and show i wonder if have they ever done
how it's made how it's made
for real behind the scenes i think they
have like they show how they do the
productions how they choose the stories
i think they've literally done that yo
it is amazing watching i watched how
they made marbles i watched one how they
made uh candy how they it's bourbon
honey
beautiful two and a half million views
it is
not only is it educational it's
hypnotizing you like you learn so much
about the mechanization process of
production seriously have your kids
watch that stuff yes so i agree with
this comment and dirty jobs too man when
people are like when mike rowe mentioned
he goes into a sewer and i'm like yes i
think this is a really really important
lesson for everybody in the kind of jobs
that we don't see
that people probably don't want to see
like
sewer maintenance
and having to go into a sewer
yeah i would disagree with the
commentator and i would just be like
don't don't rely on the state to educate
your children
and don't expect them to do a good job
at it i think i think they're being
figurative like people should have their
kids watch these shows oh absolutely
well about the civics education though
because i was thinking about that yeah
which is i as far as i know civics
education hasn't gone away i know that i
mean i'm not a child but when i was in
school we learned all about how the
government works and people have been
learning about this for generations and
yet we ended up here so i'm not sure
that teaching people how the government
functions and how to participate is
necessarily a guard against hearing your
authoritarianism or
all the ways things have gone sideways
all right madison lin says luke
beautiful eyed poc luke
have that shirt as a hoodie damn right
we already do have it as a hoodie on the
best political shirts.com and there's
multiple options women's shirts regular
shirts you name it we got it they're
going to mention that people think
they're a leftist because they have
quote people are gangs until they
explain their anti-state well police are
gangs not people i'm sorry i'm sorry
police are gangs politicians are
criminals luke luke gave me a magnesium
before the show and it it's not sitting
well really yeah it does give you it
does i told you what it does
it does good with zinc it's not making
me tired it's making me look like i'm
gonna barf i don't know yeah maybe it's
too much no this is maybe you took like
one i think you had to get you're
dehydrated well i did drink a ton of
water and i feel a lot better but i
think it might have more to do with the
fact that i may already have proper
magnesium and that was too much most
people don't actually it's the it's the
mole the center of every chlorophyll or
it's the
atom at the center of every chlorophyll
molecule it's incredible magnesium is so
powerful and it's so important for your
health
that's all the green vegetables it's
magnesium it's all about that mag
magnetic enemy g
yo kevin collins says why has no one
created billboards to expose the woke
loud in schools vaccine fo etc maybe
offer money to whistleblowers with
credible evidence of corruption in
government schools corpse military etc
any other ideas i don't know if you can
offer money for it outright like that
but project veritas are the foremost
experts on whistleblowing and stuff so
what is their email veritas tips tips at
veritas i think veritas tips at
protonmail do they still have that one
that one that sounded like james when i
said that too yeah
you know definitely you know so so i've
had people message me like hey i want to
speak up i want to challenge this stuff
and i'm just like as much as i'd love to
we are not at that point where we're
equipped to deal with anything like that
project veritas is yeah so you guys if
you notice any wrong doing
criminal activity or malfeasance talk to
the veritas guys and um
i mean they will work with you not every
story makes it you know just the way it
is but uh but veritas truly is great we
had we had james on the show yesterday
was it was awesome
all right jason says tim there's a new
ammo round coming out 8.6 blackout for
remington 700 and ar-10 type rifles
research a company called q who designed
300 blackout you have you heard of that
queue is it yeah it's one of the leading
firearms companies in the united states
and um it's not
uh the conspiracy theory it's a it's a
gun manufacturer that does really uh
well-made firearms i own one of their uh
sugar weasels which is a very yeah it's
a very fun
pistol
that is really cool to shoot in 300
blackout
all right let's uh let's grab some more
instructor uber says hey tim you're
hiring security i have seen i have seven
years of armed experience including
leadership and canine handler where can
i apply uh so
we we have security we're getting even
more security and uh
yeah uh a lot of people based on like
the vlog and other things that happened
a bit like why don't you have securities
like we do
but what you need to understand is that
i guess we're getting to the point where
i didn't think we needed
like armed guards
standing checkpoint in our acre long
driveway and things like that you know
what i mean yeah i wind up with mines
just really quickly why do you think i
was trying to set up a fight club inside
of the beanie castle i don't want
security no security we teach everyone
jiu jitsu we're going to have a jiu
jitsu class inside of the house this
thursday it's all going to be on the
vlog i've been doing kickboxing classes
self defense is definitely where it's at
and i'm being fashionable obviously we
should get security when i um we were
building mines i we learned pretty quick
that you think you're building one thing
but then immediately we needed all these
bug testers and beta testers so like we
weren't building a beta test company but
we found out after we started that
that's what we needed was a button and
so similar with security when you're
doing like a media company come turns
out it's a huge part of the organization
there's a lot of crazy people out there
yeah yeah i'll just say
you know briefly we had someone sneak in
the other day they waited my
understanding is they waited until our
guests were arriving and then tried
coming at the same time and then tried
claiming they were invited in which is a
complete lie we have surveillance
footage of it
they in order to get here you have to
drive i mean how many how how long is
the is the 100
feet no that's an understatement it's
like 1500 feet yeah it's a it's a it's
an acre long i don't i don't know how
that makes sense because acre is like
you know a square distance but it it
it's it's it's a very very long distance
and there's a there's big signs there's
multiple signs saying no admittance no
entry without permission no trespassing
you'll be prosecuted and this person
comes in here and the problem is we're
armed we were just swatted
and this person got lucky very very
lucky and we've got we've got dogs we've
got big ones we do have security
we are armed and so i'm like
this shouldn't have happened but we we
didn't you know this this person
basically waited until our guests had
all arrived when we had a group coming
in and then walks in when when when
everyone was you know occupied
and uh it shouldn't have happened but it
did we had a breach and so now we have
increased you know security 10x
and uh the police are involved and this
this guy is going to get the full brunt
of whatever there is because
when we get swatted when we get death
threats when we have people here who are
actively getting death threats and then
you think you're going to come on here
to try and get yourself promoted and lie
about what happened we can't tolerate
that no not at all not personal at all
you got to be
you got to be strong you got to be
consistent
yeah we can't we can't we can't allow
that man i mean look uh we've talked
about wanting to have people be able to
come here we talked about how we wanted
to do semi-private events where members
will be allowed to come we can't legally
do it so when someone enters the
property they're they're causing extreme
harm to everyone across the board and
putting us at serious risk all right
let's read some more we got jeremiah
jensen he says tim i am a truck driver
from west virginia in a segment today
you were talking about truck drivers not
going to big cities vaccines only play
one part drivers didn't want to go there
before this mandates was just the last
straw i noticed that you were mentioning
lydia that in like frederick the stores
were empty yeah so one of the things i
saw was that there were a bunch of empty
shelves i went into i actually tweeted
about it and then that day i went into
walmart and i saw just there was no meat
there was no chicken there's almost no
produce in frederick yes and they have a
masculine date in frederick county yeah
when i when i went to west virginia food
lion and weiss
nothing no problems i mean
when i mean nothing i say there were no
problems food was everywhere it was
great well we also went to a
a walmart in uh west virginia just down
the road from us and similar problems so
i don't know maybe it's a walmart
problem i don't know it could be uh my
also my other grocery store in frederick
there was like bear shells and people
are posting it east coast seems to be
heavily affected by these shortages
middle of the country not so much so it
might be just a little thing not sure
daniel f says trudeau is no mastermind
he's a trust fund kid with a famous last
name he is however an authoritarian
wannabe with a strong admiration for the
ccp any room for some canadian refugees
good luck
oh poor canada now now now they're doing
this vaccine canada's going to get cut
off so much of their goods get import
from the us
well you can you can thank trudeau and
everyone who voted for him
david holgwin says tim use the walking
dead season one episode two guts as a
reference for the skit if you're looking
for some help talent and putting
something together search crit short
film and tell me what you think all the
best congrats lids and andy
congratulations oh yeah
yeah thank you thank you
all right what do we got let's get some
more
stuart sockwell says in 2015 when i
became a truck driver i kept hearing
there's a shortage of truck drivers but
one day someone said to me it's harder
to demand a raise if you're replaceable
maybe there's some truth to that
oh i like this one carl andrews says
proof of gun shut up and take my money
yes
uh i i tweeted that in response thomas
massey
uh we should have gun mandates yes i
love that idea if i if man if i was in
office ronda santos should do this like
or not run to tennis but any any
republican in a democrat area should
just be like oh you're doing vax
mandates gun mandate i hereby decree i'm
the mayor of the town everyone must have
a gun and proof of gun to enter the and
then see how people react to it they're
going to be like how dare you mandate it
keeps people safe
we have data proving that guns are more
likely to be used protecting people than
to harm people than to harm the innocent
it keeps people safe ian ian there's a
pandemic with crime if it saves women
that's right that's right there's a
pandemic right
right we saw that i will not stop until
it is eradicated right it saves one life
zero murder then why not why not yeah
yeah someone mentioned too i think we'll
we'll find the super chip here we go
here we go uh zyfo says tim did you know
that the militia act of 1792 required
gun ownership and to be armed when
traveling away from home for all adult
males didn't know that
what why why would not why would you not
be armed yeah you know
look man people drive big cars all day
every day and i'm not worried about them
hitting me like obviously i look both
ways when i cross the street but i don't
think the guy in the truck is going to
just charge at me i see people on west
virginia armed all the time i'm not
worried about them shooting me i don't
go like oh no oh they got a weapon it's
like
people got cars if they want to use them
they can use them in bad ways people got
guns and use them in bad ways
all right kyle beckman says did i just
hear that tim now opposes universal
health care if not you should ask
parents in canada uk how long it takes
to get kids diagnosed with autism and
start therapy
i'll put it this way
my my criticism was california doubling
their tax rate to pay for it and to just
drive rich people away from the state
and they would have no funds to pay for
it i think realistically we we we as a
nation will struggle to implement
something on a mass scale i think
idealistically wouldn't it be great if
we could have a functioning medical
system universally for everybody the
problem is as ian mentioned you can't
because people don't take care of
themselves let food be thy medicine
that's what hippocrates the father of
modern medicine instructed everyone to
do what i mean is food if you want
universal health care you also need to
mandate people do early morning
calisthenics diet i mean the medical
industry and the food industry are so
intertwined now after what was it the in
1910 they signed the uh
some some some act got signed in 1910
where the medical industry basically
they started to do away with homeopathic
medicine and uh the flexner report it
was the name of the report that got they
got issued but it's the food if you're
gonna feed someone sugar and then give
them prozac to counteract the negative
things like that's the same industry
basically essentially this is why it
won't work because basically if you try
and do universal health care
a leak will spring up in your boat
you'll stick your finger and another
leak will pop and you'll keep trying to
plug all the holes which you can't do
so ultimately you just need
decentralization yeah i don't think you
can allow actual freedom i think that uh
centralized healthcare is going to
require a great deal of authoritarianism
that we don't want especially in a
country 330 million people it's not
gonna work or serious cultural changes
yeah and the thing too is the health
care system is already so corrupted
there these interests have already
overtaken congress like who are you
expecting to do this in a way that isn't
built on a bedrock of cronyism and
corruption that isn't really looking out
for people's best interests so the idea
is really nice but pragmatically and
realistically i don't think
everybody in america is going to
re-elect progressive-only politicians
who are going to scrap the entire system
and then build a brand new one which
would already have its own issues
because of the centralization
all right we got murph he says tim what
are you gonna have awaken with jp on the
show as soon as jp wants to come on the
show
he's gonna be in dc for the rally
happening soon so maybe we'll get in
contact with him then jp if you hear
this message
come on the show yeah we're here in the
dc we're not far from dc we're an hour
away uh that'd be awesome uh jp's
awesome i need guests that'd be cool
let's go
yeah
all right
jamie says i approve of your
i approve of your proof of pewpew
that's right i like that you walk up to
a diner and they're like excuse me do
you have your guns uh yes i have it
right here ah excellent and your wife uh
honey do you have your your your glock
on you i do and your children i see you
have a young boy yes he's got his ar
with him oh wonderful and your and your
young seven-year-old daughter she does
have like a like what would she have she
doesn't have one though we have one here
that she can use
that would be good here and then like
all they have are really big ones
they've got you know a bear
like well she can't carry that it's okay
what's what's that meme where it's like
uh children are not children and guns do
not mix they're too heavy and then it
was like children are better suited for
crew served weapons
it builds teamwork and this and the
mobile nature of the weapons allows them
to better handle them
with the crew serve machine gun
when they walk in they're like oh i
noticed your young daughter doesn't have
a weapon don't worry and then she like
they walk over and there's like a rack
of things like
here you go you can have this one
i couldn't think of any of the good
really small weapons i had and i also
couldn't decide if she should eve if the
young girl should even get a smaller
weapon and she'd just get a standard one
yeah
mr toad says tim you quote it often the
movie network but have you seen it how
accurate do you think it is i have a
really really long time ago uh when i
was like really young so i don't i don't
remember i have to re-watch it for sure
but you guys remember that movie i'm mad
as hell and i'm not gonna take it
anymore yeah you gotta open the windows
or whatever like scream at me they used
to tell me i was that guy you know i
heard the youtube videos yeah
i never saw it
tank art says if you read the history of
the spanish flu of 1918 it was about two
years of it and it was covered up by the
media by the order of the welton
administration because of world war one
last wave was weak antibodies lasted 90
years wow crazy yeah i read i read a
decent a bit about it and like the
trenches were making it worse people
were getting sick and they were filthy
and injured and oh geez
just really really bad
all right we'll just grab we'll grab a
couple more let's see if we can get in
here
free men die free says healthcare was
number one in the u.s prior to medicare
medicaid et cetera subsidies in
government intervention is always the
problem doctors used to come to your
home that's true remember those stories
doctor would show up to be honest though
back then medical treatment was
something different biting a bullet they
didn't have anesthetic really they would
have you know during civil war yeah you
die by choking instead of by you know
man it's kind of crazy that they had to
amputate your leg instead of just
splashing some soap on it
we are really lucky antiseptics man no
joke that's why
you know we we got a bunch of uh i think
did you order the isopropyl
no joke and it's not like just god given
that you have it in your house it's not
a co that's it's it's not it basically
cured the black plague
they didn't have soap so they had a
plague instead but now you have soap so
use it all right we got one more here
let's uh let's read this
the belsnickel says i got a fever and
the only prescription is more brent
mason's signature telecaster much love
and respect for maisy kerry lake for
governor that is right that is right
behind me is the brent mason signature
telecaster
it's so good it's so amazing
uh i'm just a bit it's an excellent
guitar and more importantly if you watch
brent mason actually play the guitar
you're just like he's like a robot it's
just some of the best guitar playing
i've ever seen and uh just on the side
you know it's just hanging up there
because it's a really great little
instrument and i'm stoked to have to
have one but my friends
you should go to timcast.com and become
a member right now because we have a
members only segment coming up for you
we publish them around 11 or so p.m we
swear a lot they're uncensored they get
spicy so you want to check it out you
can also follow the show at timcast irl
follow us on instagram we post clips all
day every day you can follow me at tim
cast basically everywhere else carrie do
you want to shout anything out
you can find me on twitter carrie
underscore weddler i'm on youtube
i don't know if my channel is
compromised as far as reach but i would
love it if you went to my channel and
checked it out and you can find me on
instagram i was recently banned from
tiktok but i'm hoping to be back
i'm thinking about starting a tick tock
i might do it i'm thinking about getting
banned on tick-tock myself
thank you ian i appreciate that i made a
pretty interesting video about the end
of kovid on youtube.com forward slash we
are change check that out if you have
some time and i made a spicier one about
prince andrew on
lukeuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks so much for having
me and this was a great conversation
great having my fellow anarcho-memist
yes
whatever
thanks for coming your youtube channel
carrie weddler it is yeah hey everybody
we are change.org
thank
you guys can follow me at ian
crossland.net i'm ian crossland thanks
for coming kerry great to see you yeah
thanks you guys for having me i meant to
say that definitely
and thank you guys all very much for
tuning in we will see you guys in the
after show and then tomorrow you guys
may follow me on twitter at
sarahpatchlids we will see you all at
timcast.com sign up support our
journalists support our work and we'll
see you all in the members only show bye
you